bonjour à tous vous allez pouvoir suivre
dans un instant la discussion générale
sur la réforme du droit d'asile un texte
examiné depuis hier soir ici au Sénat et
avant même son examen le texte a donné
lieu à de vives échanges entre le
gouvernement et l'opposition manuel Vals
le Premier ministre accusant même
l'opposition de bloquer l'examen du
texte de façon incohérente alors
concrètement le projet de loi visa à
fluidifier un système engorgé il
ambitionne de réduire de 2 ans à 9 mois
le délai de traitement des dossiers les
amendements adoptés en commission ici au
Sénat vont dans le sens d'un
durcissement vis-à-vis des déboutés un
amendement propose ainsi que les rejets
de demande d'asile vaillent
automatiquement obligation de quitter le
territoire un autre amendement propose
que les déboutés ne puissent pu
solliciter un titre de séjour sous un
autre motif comme le regroupement
familial par exemple voilà tout de suite
donc je vous propose d'écouter Bernard
casenu le ministre de
l'Intérieur l'ordre du jour appelle la
discussion du projet de loi adopté par
l'Assemblée nationale après engagement
de la procédure accélérée relatif à la
réforme de l'asile dans la discussion
générale la parole est à Monsieur
Bernard casenu ministre de l'Intérieur
vous avez la parole monsieur le
ministre
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
rapporteur mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs comment ne pas songer au
moment où s'ouvre notre discussion sur
la réforme du droit d'asile au drame qui
se joue actuellement en
Méditerranée plus de 1700 hommes femmes
et enfants il ont déjà perdu la vie en
2015 victime de trafiquants de passe
qui n'hésite pas après les avoir
rançonné à envoyer des migrants à la
mort sur des embarcations de fortune
comme vous le savez le Conseil européen
réuni en urgence le 23 avril a dégagé
des premières orientations pour répondre
à cette crise migratoire secourir les
migrants en détresse et répartir
l'effort entre les différents
États-membres le triplement des moyens
de secours dédiés à l'agence Frontex le
renforcement de notre coopération avec
les pays d'origine et de transit comme
la lutte contre les filières de passeurs
traduisent cette volonté
européenne la France conformément à sa
vocation s'est porté aux avant-postes de
cette mobilisation et continuera
d'ailleurs à le faire l'agenda pour
lesmigration que la Commission
européenne adoptera mercredi devrait
s'inspirer en grande parti des
propositions de la France sur le
renforcement des moyens de Frontex sur
le renforce de la coopération avec les
pays de transit et d'origine je me rends
d'ailleurs au Niger mercredi et jeudi
pour traiter de ce sujet sur la mise en
place d'une véritable politique
européenne commune de l'asile combinant
responsabilité et solidarité des
États-membres de l'Union
européenne sur la mise en place d'un
programme pilote de réinstallation des
réfugiés syriens au niveau
européen sur un soutien renforcé aux
étatsmembres les plus concernés par les
afflux de migrants afin qu'il qu'il
puisse plus efficacement protéger les
personnes en besoin de protection
éloigner dans des conditions de dignité
de respect des droits les personnes
relevant de l'immigration
irrégulière le projet de loi dont vous
êtes saisi s'inscrit parfaitement dans
cette initiative européenne mieux il
l'anticipe face à la grave crise
migratoire que rencontre l'Europe la
France joue tout son rôle en adoptant
une réforme qui rende soutenable la
demande d'asile en France et qui
contribuera efficacement à l'initiative
européenne conduite par Jean-Claude
Junker à laquelle nous apportons tout
notre soutien je veux à cet effet
rappeler les choses très clairement nous
avons collectivement je vous le dis à
tous une exigence de vérité et d'action
pour faire taire les fantasmes sur
lesquels prospère tous les extrémismes
l'augmentation brutale des flux en
Méditerranée n'est pané du hasard elle
résulte directement du chaos
libien la Libye n'est en effet plus en
mesure de contrôler ses
frontièr c'est de ces côtes que partent
les migrants qui croient trouver en
Europe le rêve que d'autres leur ont
vendu en leur
mentant je veux toujours au titre de
cette exigence de vérité dissiper une
confusion qui a prospéré dans le tumulte
médiatique la France est loin d'être le
pays le plus concerné par ses flux
migratoires en provenance de la
Méditerranée
elle est loin aussi d'être le pays le
plus concerné en Europe par la demande
d'asile
elle est et cela doit d'ailleurs
interroger tous les démagogues qui
affirment que notre pis serait la proie
de migrants résolu à capter je ne sais
quelle aide que nous octroirions trop
généreusement le seul pays de l'Union
européenne à avoir connu une baisse de
la demande d'asile en 2014 de
2,34 % et les chiffres de la demande
d'asile sur les premiers mois de l'année
2015 sont pour l'instant stables cela
signifie une chose la France est pour
ces migrants un pays de transit et non
un pays d'installation cela pose des
questions pour autant très difficiles
notamment à Calais mais de grâce
n'exploitons pas comme j'ai pu le lire
ça et là les drame en Méditerranée pour
faire peur aux Français
ou soudain inviter le gouvernement à je
ne sais quel changement de
cap comprenons bien ensemble l'urgence
de ce texte les migrants qui traversent
la Méditerranée ne relèvent pas tous de
l'asile mais certains à l'évidence les
Syriens les éitréens les Irakiens en
relèv et leur arrivée sur les côtes
européennes impose à chaque État membre
de l'Union européenne et par conséquent
à la France d'avoir des procédures
d'asile qui soient efficaces
rationnelles réactives et conforme aux
meilleurs standards européens cette
exigence de transposition de nos règles
communes fait d'ailleurs partie
intégrante des conclusions des 28 chefs
d'État et de gouvernement et de la
communication sur l'agenda des
migrations qui sera présentée mercredi
par la Commission européenne or et c'est
un point d'accord entre tout tous les
républicains l'exercice du droit d'asile
est fragilisé en France notre dispositif
en la matière est au bord de l'embolie
le texte qui vous est présenté est donc
en prise avec une actualité brûlante et
je dois le dire c'est pour moi une
fierté particulière de présenter dans ce
contexte si difficile un texte qui
répond aux urgences du moment et qui a
recueilli un large assentiment à
l'Assemblée nationale à l'occasion de sa
première lecture et de son vote mais
avant d'entrer dans le détail du texte
je veux insister sur l'esprit dans
lequel il a été
rédigé je sais que la volonté de
réformer notre système d'asile rassemble
tous les républicains quel que soit la
formation politique à laquelle ils
appartiennent et ce pour une raison
simple d'ailleurs c'est que l'histoire
du droit d'asile et l'histoire de la
République et de la démocratie en France
sont deux histoires intimement liées
l'une à l'autre voilà pourquoi le projet
de loi déposé par le Gouvernement est
d'abord un texte de
rassemblement fruit d'une réflexion et
d'une mobilisation de longue haleine à
laquelle nous sommes nombreux à avoir
contribué en juillet 2013 mon
prédécesseur manuel Vals avait ainsi
organiser une concertation nationale sur
le droit d'asile qui a rassemblé
l'ensemble des acteurs concernés l'état
bien sûr qui doit prendre ses
responsabilité et il les prend les
collectivités locales les associations
le Haut Commissariat au réfugiés
l'Office français de protection des
réfugiés des apatrides la Cour nationale
du droit d'asile l'Office français de
l'immigration et de
l'intégration votre collègue Valérie
lettard et le député Jean-Louis Touren
ont coordonné ses travaux et je voudrais
une fois de plus saluer leur travail
remarquable c'est sur ces bases que le
texte qui vous est soumis à recueilli à
l'Assemblée nationale une large majorité
à l'issue d'un débat de qualité
débarrasser des postures
partisanes je sais aussi que sur de
nombreux bancs de cette assemblée des
sénateurs se passionnent pour
l'asile je pense bien sûr au rapporteur
François Noël buffet que je veux
remercier pour sa contribution en
commission à l'élaboration de ce texte à
nos débats je pense à Roger carucci
auteur d'un rapport d'information
consacré au centre provisoire
d'hébergement et au coup de notre
politique d'asile d'une manière générale
à Jean compte à Jean-Pierre suur
toujours mobilisé sur ces questions qui
mêlent intimement République et humanité
et je sais que nous aurons sans doute
des échanges riches avec Esther ben
Bassa Ian Assassi qui ont eu je le
devine une lecture critique et fine du
texte que je propose à votre
délibération s'il y a eu un consensus
fort à l'Assemblée nationale c'est parce
que nous avons pris le temps du
diagnostic ce diagnostic a été fait et
refait il est établi il est largement
partagé le relevé d'observation
provisoire récent de la Cour des comptes
dont la presse s'est fait l'écho
opportunément n'a fait que confirmer
parfois en ajoutant d'ailleurs de la
confusion ou de l'imprécision les
dysfonctionnements que les
parlementaires de tout bord des
associations des institutions avaient
dénoncé ces dysfonctionnements je veux
les redire simplement en quelques
phrases notre système d'asile souffre de
grve carence alors que la demande
d'asile a presque doublé entre 2007 et
2012 doublé de 35000 demandes à
62000 aucune mesure n'a été prise pour
gérer cet accroissement aucune la
demande a continué à s'accroître en 2013
avant que l'année 2014 soit marquée par
un léger retournement de tendance
paradoxal d'ailleurs dans le contexte
international
actuel selon les données collectées par
l'OFPRA plus de 64 56 demandes ont été
déposé l'année dernière soit une
diminution je le redis de 2,34 % par
rapport à l'année précédente les délais
à l'AUPR comme à la CNDA se sont
allongés
considérablement jusqu'à 2 ans les
hébergements s'en sont trouvés saturés
les inégalités de traitement entre
demandeurs s'en sont trouvé accru les
droits minimaux qui leur sont dus au
titre des règles européennes n'ont plus
été assurés le cout budgétaire de
l'ensemble a cessé d'être
maîtrisé la gestion locale de la demande
d'asile s'en est trouvée plus difficile
puisque 2 tiers des demandeurs sont
concentrés dans deux régions seulement
de France c'est àez
dysfonctionnement
incontestable connu et insoutenable à
court terme que le projet de loi veut
répondre derrière sa technicité
apparente il en effet tris ob obctif
simple que je veux rappeler devant votre
assemblée d'abord réduire drastiquement
les délais d'examen d'une demande
d'asile deuxèmement améliorer les
conditions d'accueil et d'hébergement
des demandeurs d'asile en mettant en
place un hébergement directif
troisièement accroître les droits des
demandeurs d'asile en transposant
exactement les directives applicables
nous entendons premièrement tout d'abord
réduire à 9 mois en moyenne la durée
totale de l'examen d'une demande
à l'heure actuelle celle-ci peut
facilement excéder 2 ans contre moins
d'un an en moyenne chez nos principaux
partenaires européens ce premier
objectif constitue un préalable à toute
amélioration de la situation que vivent
les demandeurs d'asile des procédures
trop longues freinent l'accès au statut
de réfugiés pour les demandeurs qui sont
fondés à l'obtenir mais rendre également
notre dispositif plus vulnérable aux
tenta de détournement à des fins
d'immigration
irrégulière enfin elle complique
l'éloignement des
déboutés la priorité est donc
d'accélérer les délais d'examen devant
l'aupra charger des demandes en première
instance mais aussi devant la CNDA cours
spécialisé que le projet de loi entend
maintenir et renforcer en effet à chaque
étape les délais sont excessifs sans
parler du temps que prennent les
échanges d'information entre toutes les
institutions concernées ni même
d'ailleurs les délis cachés tels que
celui de l'enregistrement de la demande
en préfecture il est donc pas acceptable
de laisser si longtemps dans une telle
situation d'incertitude ceux et celles
qui font confiance à la France pour les
protéger voilà pourquoi l'OFPRA et la
CNDA seront dotés en 2015 d'importants
moyens humains supplémentaires 55
équivalent temps plein ont d'ors et déjà
été attribués recrutés par l'OFPRA c'est
un effort exceptionnel qui n'a jamais
été fait qu'a consenti le gouvernement
de tels renforts permettront à l'OFPRA
dès 2016 d'accélérer ces procédures afin
de limiter à 3 mois la durée moyenne
d'examen d'une demande d'asile la CNDA
quant à elle bénéficiera d'un renfort de
magistrat et de rapporteurs afin
d'accompagner la réforme de ces
procédure les demandes en procédure
accéléré devont être examiné en moins de
se semaines par un juge unique les
demandes en procédure normale en moins
de 5 mois par une formation collégiale
pour ce faire nous prévoyons en out de
simplifier un certain nombre de règles
devant la Cour notamment celle qui
concerne l'aide
juridictionnelle nous devons également
simplifier nos procédures d'asile en
amont les délais d'enregistrement des
demandes par les préfectures sont
beaucoup trop longs ils devront être
ramenés à 3 jours grâce à la création de
tichers unique de l'accueil du demandeur
d'asile qui regrouperont dans un même
site dans un même lieu les agents de
l'OFI et ceux des préfectures enfin nous
devons savoir distinguer entre les
demandes d'asile qui méritent un examen
approfondi et celles pour lesquelles la
réponse semble évidente et qui donc
peuvent être traité plus rapid
c'est aussi de cette façon que nous
réduirons sensiblement les délais de
procédure l'OFPRA c'est traité
rapidement des demandes qui sont
manifestement fondées T cell des Syriens
ou des chrétiens d'irac à l'inverse
d'autres demandes ne nécessite pas un
examen approfondi dans la mesure où elle
ne repose sur aucun motif
sérieux pour cette raison le texte
réforme les placements en procédures
prioritaires celle-ci devenant la
procédure accéléré le texte qui vous est
soumis exploite toutes les possibilités
offertes toutes les possibilités
offertes par les directif de placement
en procédure accélérée toutes quand on
souhaite réduire les délais on utilise
tous les moyens disponibl entre les
mains de l'administration pour atteindre
l'objectif par ailleurs et parce que
c'est un texte
d'équilibre le projet de loi réalise
deux avancées
essentielles il à l'ofpr qui seul a
accès au contenu de la demande le soin
de dire en dernière instance si un
dossier doit faire l'objet ou non d'un
placement en procédure accélérée il
garantit au demandeurs d'asile en
procédure accélérée les mêmes droits à
un hébergement à une allocation un
recours suspensif qui un demandeur en
procédure normale ça demande est certes
examiné plus vite mais ces droits sont
intégralement et tous
notre deuxième objectif est d'améliorer
l'accueil et l'hébergement des
demandeurs d'asile actuellement notre
système est bien trop
inégalitaire pour cette raison il
n'honore pas la République certains
demandeurs sont hébergés en centre
d'accueil pour demandeur d'asile il
bénéficient à ce titre d'un
accompagnement administratif social
juridique dont chacun jusqu'au milieu
associatif les plus engagés loue
qualité ce n'est en revanche pas le cas
des de tiers d'entre eux qui sont soit
pris en charge dans des structures
d'hébergement d'urgence soit sont tout
simplement livrés à eux-mêmes et
survivent tant bien que mal dans des
campants de fortune cette différence de
traitement n'est pas tolérable elle doit
cesser d'ici à 2017 l'hébergement en
cada doit donc devenir la norme et
l'hébergement d'urgence
l'exception nous allons pour ce de faire
augmenter le nombre de places en cada
nous en avons déjà créé 4000 de plus en
2 ans et nous avons l'ambition d'en
ouvrir encore 5000 d'ici l'année
prochaine par création nette ou bien en
transformant certaines places
d'hébergement d'urgence nous devons
ensuite en finir avec les allocations
éclatées dont bénéficient des demandeurs
d'asile l'allocation temporaire
d'attente et laallocation mensuelle de
subsistance seront fondus en une
allocation unique qui prendra en compte
situation familiale de chaque demandeur
enfin nous allons et c'est un point
indissociable des deux précédents mettre
en place un véritable hébergement
directif comme vous le savez l'accueil
des demandeurs d'asile peut-être
difficile à gérer sur le terrain
lorsqu'un trop grand nombre d'entre eux
converge en même temps vers un même
point du territoire aujourd'hui de
territoire la région parisienne et la
région liyonnaise ençin Noë buffet le sa
bien concentre plus de la moitié des
demandes l'Île-de-France concentre à
elle seule 42 % des demandeurs d'asile
et je n'ignore pas non plus les
difficultés rencontrées en Alsace en
Bretagne en Lorine c'est la République
qui offre l'asile à ceux qui en ont
besoin et non tel ou tel
territoire par conséquent afin de mieux
répartir l'effort nous prévoyons de
mettre en place une orientation
directive des
demandeurs mieux orienter leur accueil
permettra également de mieux les
accompagner
et de leur offrir de meilleures
conditions
d'hébergement concrètement le versement
d'une allocation dépendra de la
sollicitation puis de l'acceptation d'un
hébergement si un demandeur ne souhaite
pas bénéficier des conditions d'accueil
prévu par la République ou s'il ne
souhaite pas aller là où une place est
disponible pour le recevoir il aura
naturellement droit à un examen de sa
demande d'asile en revanche et ne pourra
pas bénéficier de l'hébergement ni des
allocations prévues j'y insiste il
s'agit là d'un point crucial qui
conditionne le succès de la réforme
enfin le trème objectif de cette réforme
consiste à renforcer les droits des
demandeurs d'asile dans un souci
d'égalité de juste transposition des
normes européennes c'est un élément
essentiel car c'est la démonstration que
le raccourcissement des délais et
l'augmentation des droits des demandeurs
d'asile sont deux objectifs que l'on
peut poursuivre
simultanément ainsi le demandeur d'asile
pour AA désormais bénéficier à l'OFPRA
d'un conseil de son choix de même qu'il
pourra s'il le souhaite accéder de plein
droit à l'aide juridictionnelle devant
la
CNDA les demandes d'asile en situation
de vulnérabilité pourront également
bénéficier d'un examen et d'une prise en
charge adapté à leur
situation je pense bien sûr aux mineurs
je pense aussi aux femmes victimes en
tant que femmes des pires
atrocités enfin la loi permettra à tous
les demandeurs d'asile en procédure
normale comme en procédure accélérée de
bénéficier d'un droit au maintien sur le
territoire pendant l'examen de leur
demande c'est-à-dire de bénéficier de
l'ensemble des droits qui sont
aujourd'hui reconnus aux demandeur en
procédure
normale je ne peux aborder la question
de l'asile sans avoir une pensée pour
l'outrem et notamment pour Mayotte et
pour la Guyane c'est débartements sont
confrontés à une pression migratoire
exceptionnelle dont je sais qu'elle
peut-être pour ces territoire
déstabilisante la demande d'asile peut-
y être perçue en raison de l'éloignement
de la longueur des procédures comme une
difficulté
supplémentaire je veux devant vous
prendre l'engagement que le gouvernement
vaillera dans la mise en œuvre de ce
projet de loi à ce qu'il apporte dans
ces territoires des solutions concrètes
pour en finir je veux dire un mot du
sujet qui a subitement inquiété me
suis-je laissé dire la commission des
Lois du Sénat je veux parler des
déboutés du droit d'asile
le gouvernement n'a pas attendu le
relevé de conclusion de la Cour des
comptes pour prendre la mesure des
difficultés sur ce sujet et je veux dire
ici les choses très simplement très
clairement un débouté de l'asile et sauf
s'il bénéficie d'un droit au séjour pour
un autre motif un étranger en situation
irrégulière il doit donc c'est la
démarche du gouvernement quitter le
territoire et regagner son pays
d'origine comme tout étranger en
situation irrégulière et la lutte contre
l'immigration irrégulière est une
priorité de ce gouvernement et de mon
ministère et je ne suis pas certain en
la matière que ceux qui se posent en
conseilleur sur ces sujets aimeraient
que je livre les résultats chiffrés
auxquels ont pu mener d'autres
politiques nous avons confié la
comptabilisation des éloignements à un
service statistique
indépendant qui dépend de l'INC c'était
comme en matière de délinquence une
décision destinée à créer les conditions
de la transparence et de la fiabilité
des
données quand nous avons fait ce choix
il est apparu qu'une fois que l'on
enlevait des retours aidés de Roumains
et de Bulgares retrouve provisoire et
par conséquent fictif puisque les
bénéficiaires ne tardaient pas à revenir
en France après avoir perçu leur prime
une fois donc que l'on supprima les
comptabilisations de ces ressortissants
de l'Union Européenne la politique
d'éloignement de la France au sens des
normes européennes qui sont celles qui
doivent servir de référence était en
vérité effondré
entre 2007 et 2011 effondré on donnait
une prime au roumains au bulgares qui
partaient à Noël dans leur pays
revenaent après Noël reprenaiit la prime
à PAC avant que de revenir après PAC
tout cela alimenta des comptabilisations
avantageuses qui n'avait absolument rien
à voir avec la détermination à mener une
politique en ces domaines remettre sur
pied une politique d'éloignement
efficace et respectueuse des droits
c'est l'engagement que nous avons pris
c'est l'engagement que je veux tenir
devant la représentation nationale nous
avons dans cet esprit réalisé deux
choses d'abord nous avons remobilisé
l'ensemble des services qui en avaient
besoin quatre circulaires traitant de la
lutte contre l'immigration irrégulière
ont été publiés entre 2013 et
2015 des plans d'action ont été élaborés
par chaque préfecture les aides au
retour ont été retravaillé par l'OFI à
ma demande qui a inclus à ce dispositif
un véritable volet de réinsertion dans
le pays d'origine nous n'avons pas
ménagé nos efforts parce que la
République ce sont des règles et je le
dis là aussi clairement et fermement
devant la représentation nationale et
que ces règles doivent être
rigoureusement
respectées quels sont les résultats de
cette politique les retours contraints
notamment vers un pays tiers à l'Union
européenne qui s'était effondré entre
2007 et 2011 repartent à la hausse
depuis 3 ans je veux donner ici des
chiffres précis qui sont vérifiable à la
fois par la commission et par quelques
observateurs qui ont écrit des articles
percutants mais que je n'ai pas toujours
trouvé honnêtement et convenablement
documenté en
2013 les retours contraints ont augmenté
de 13 % et d'environ 25 % l'année
dernière en 2014 la France a connu le
plus haut niveau d'éloignement contraint
depuis 2007 avec
éloignements je ne dis pas que nous
réussissons là où d'autres ont échoué je
dis simplement que tout le monde doit
sur cette politique difficile faire
preuve de la plus grande humilité par
ailleurs mes services sont également
pleinement mobilisés dans la la lutte
contre les filières d'immigration
irrégulière qui tirent profit de la
misère humaine qui sont de véritables
filières de la traite des êtres humains
là aussi quels sont les résultats de
notre action l'année dernière nous avons
démentelé près de 230 filières
clandestines 226 très exactement ce qui
constitue un record historique et
représente 25 % de filièr de
l'immigration irrégulière démantelée de
plus qu'en
2012 la détermination
n'est pas toujours accompagné des
discours qui visent à
l'instrumentalisation de ces questions
en étant oubliux des chiffres des
réalités des actions et des artifices
qui ont pu être mobilisés pour atteindre
des objectifs chiffré qui ne
correspondait pas toujours aux
nécessités de l'urgence en second lieu
je tiens à rappeler que nous avons
inclus dans le projet de loi sur le
séjour je le précise parce qu'il m'est
arrivé parfois de me demander si cela
avait été
intégré projet de loi sur le séjour dont
la discussion au Parlement débutera dans
les prochaines semaines l'ensemble des
dispositions qui apparaissent
nécessaires à l'amélioration de nos
dispositifs dans le respect du droit et
des
droits un débouté du droit d'asile je le
disais c'est un étranger en situation
irrégulière il n'y a pas de raison
juridique aucune sauf à prendre des
risques
juridiques de créer des dispositifs
spécifique deséloignements qui serait
spécifiquement réservés au débouté du
droit d'asile personne personne aucun
gouvernement ne l'a jamais fait ce
serait d'ailleurs une bien étrange
application des garanties
constitutionnelles qui entourent le
droit d'asile si un étranger en
situation irrégulière parce qu'il a fait
une demande d'asile se voyait appliquer
des règles plus rigoureuses qu'un autre
étranger en situation irrégulière qui
n'aurait pas fait cette demande c'est la
raison pour laquelle les réformes
concernant l'ensemble des étrangers en
situation irrégulière déboutter de
l'asile ou non trouve leur place dans le
texte sur le séjour qui sera débattu non
pas à la saintlinglin mais en juillet à
l'Assemblée nationale en septembre
devant votre assemblée ou au plus tard
en octobre c'est-à-dire dans une
continuité d'examen par le Parlement des
textes si bien que si nous sommes
désireux sur ce sujet d'être pragmatique
et efficace de faire montre d'humanité
de responsabilité de fermeté quand c'est
nécessaire si nous sommes désireux de ne
pas instrumentaliser cette question à
des fins politiques partisanes et
peut-être même électorales alors nous
serons en situation d'ici à la fin de
l'année d'avoir voté l'ensemble des
dispositions qui permettront à la France
d'affirmer la vocation qui a toujours
été la sienne dans l'histoire au regard
du droit d'asile et de procéder à la
reconduite à la frontière de ceux qui
déboutaient du droit d'asile n'ont pas
eu à l'accès à l'asile en France parce
qu'il ne relevait pas de ce
dispositif donc le
gouvernement propose au Sénat une
approche globale qui permet de renouer
avec l'asile qui permet d'avoir une
politique à l'égard de l'immigration qui
soit apaisée et qui à cet effet prévoit
de renforcer la lutte résolue contre
l'immigration
irrégulière le gouvernement là encore
est dans l'action il n'est pas dans le
commentaire il se refuse à être dans
l'approximation et j'aurai l'occasion
soit dans le cadre de cette discussion
général soit à l'occasion des
discussions que nous aurons sur certains
amendements adoptés en commission de
vous dire que l'ensemble de vos
préoccupations est bien prise en compte
par le gouvernement mais avec un souci
un souci constant qui est celui du
respect des normes européennes
internationales et le souci de
l'efficacité ainsi par exemple la
commission des lois en adoptant un
amendement privant le débouté d'une
demande d'asile de toute possibilité
d'admission au séjour à un autre titre
commet à mon avis une double erreur
juridique d'une part il en résulterait
une inégalité de traitement entre les
demandeurs d'asile débouté et les autres
étrangers en situation régulière qui
n'est pas explicable et qui est
contraire au Droit constitutionnel de
l'asile d'autre part les admissions au
séjour obéissent le plus souvent à des
contraintes résultant de normes
européennes les interdire c'est nous
exposer une condamnation certaine de la
France par les juridictions nationales
et européennes ce n'est qu'un exemple
mais il est révélateur je ne pense pas
une minute que ces arguments juridiques
de bon sens soient inconnus des membres
éminents de la commission des lois
pourquoi alors adopter des amendements
dont on sait pertinemment qu'il nous
emmène dans des impaces juridiques
pourquoi réclamer des choses dont on
sait
l'inconstitutionnalité ou
l'inconventionnalité le gouver
gouvernement pour sa part contribuera à
ce débat dans un esprit républicain
c'est-à-dire un esprit de responsabilité
votre commission des Lois effué un
important travail que je tiens à saluer
je pense notamment au rapporteur
François Noël buffet qui parfois
améliore d'ailleurs ces amendements ces
modifications le texte néanmoins
certaines des modifications apporté au
texte ne reflètent pas les orientations
du gouvernement et pose de réels
problèmes constitutionnels nous aurons
l'occasion d'y revenir à travers
l'examen des amendements outre certaines
dispositions relatives au déboutés dont
j'ai déjà parlé c'est par exemple le
quand en matière de compétences
contentieuse ou d'hébergement directifs
le gouvernement entend aborder chacune
de ces questions avec la plus grande
rigueur et la sérénité qui caractérise
toujours les débats au sein de votre
assemblée mesdames et messieurs ne nous
trompons pas de débat il y a urgence
contenu des drames humanitaires auquel
le monde est confronté à réformer nos
procédures d'asile nous proposons j'en
suis convaincu une réforme à la fois
globale et équilibré avec l'amélioration
de nos dispositifs d'intégration
l'accueil des étudiants et des talents
étrangers la lutte contre l'immigration
irrégulière la réforme du droit d'asile
est l'un des quatre piliers le plus
symbolique sans doute de notre politique
à l'égard des étrangers en France cette
politique globale fait l'objet de deux
projets de loi qui ser on tous les deux
discutter je le souhaite adopter avant
la fin de l'année j'ajoute qu'en faisant
deux lois dans la même séquence
parlementaire une sur l'immigration une
autre sur l'asile ce gouvernement
n'innove pas c'est exactement ce qui
avait été proposé à la représentation
nationale en
2003 personne à l'époque n'avait
considéré que ce fut
irresponsable aujourd'hui est venu le
temps du débat sur la réforme de l'asile
c'est un débat indispensable égard à
l'ampleur des dysfonctionnements que je
viens de rappeler c'est une réforme
urgente si la France veut tenir son rang
dans la gestion des flux migratoires
auquel l'Europe est
confrontée je ne suis pas ignorant bien
entendu des contingences politiques je
n'ai sur ces sujets aucune forme de
naïveté je comprends parfaitement les
positionnements et les tactiques il
m'arrive pas parfois de comprendre d'où
elles peuvent venir mais je forme le
vœux que sur un sujet aussi fondamental
et aussi lié à notre identité
républicaine nous sachions ensemble
faire honneur à la réputation de la
République à la longue tradition de
débat apaisé de qualité qui ont toujours
caractériser votre assemblée nous
pourrons ainsi aller sereinement au fond
des choses c'est en tout cas le souhait
profond du gouvernement je vous remercie
merci Monsieur le
Ministre la parole est à à Monsieur
François Noël buffet rapporteur de la
commission des
lois qu'est-ce qu'on m'a porter à boire
c'est
bien monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre monsieur
le président de la commission des lois
monsieur le rapporteur pour avis
chers collègues quelques quelques mots
au moment où vient devant notre
assemblée un texte important tous les
textes sont importants bien sûr mais
celui-ci je pense l'
particulièrement car dans le cadre des
politiques que doit mener notre pays la
politique de
l'asile ne touche pas des marchandises
mais touche des personnes et qu'à ce
titre là nous avons l'impérieuse
nécessité et le devoir d'être vigilant
sur tout ce que nous
faisons mais bien sûr cette vigilance et
le souci qui est le nottre collectif de
doter notre pays de moyens qui lui
permettent de pouvoir mener ses
politiques ne doit pas nous empêcher de
regarder la triste réalité tout d'abord
la triste
actualité nous ramène au qutidien de
certaines
populations à la rencontre mortifère de
voyage organisés par des réseaux mafieux
laissans croire que sur le territoire
européen ou en France en particulier
l'Eldorado serait là et que profitant de
ce mirage ils empochent des sommes
conséquentes naturellement au détriment
de ceux qu'il prétendent
aider le sujet de l'asile certains
parfois pas tous ont tendance à le
confondre avec celui de
l'immigration il convient bien sur ce
sujet de dire l'instant à cette tribune
que les sujets sont
différents l'asile est une chose
l'immigration est une autre il y a
l'immigration régulière il est bien
normal que notre pays se dote d'une
politique migratoire mais ça n'est pas
le sujet aujourd'hui peut-être c'est
dommage il y a l'immigration clandestine
contre laquelle nous devons lutter
fermement mais la politique de l'asile
c'est d'abord et avant toute chose
l'application de la Convention de Genève
de
1951 et c'est le devoir ou l'engagement
de la France
d'accorder à ceux qui sont menacés dans
leur
pays de leur accorder une protection et
que cette protection le but de la
procédure qui est la
nôtre c'est pas forcément de dire non à
tous c'est de répondre rapidement à ceux
qui ont no besoins pour leur donner
cette
protection la difficulté qui est la
nôtre aujourd'hui dans notre droit dans
la situation de fait c'est que cette
procédure d'asile pour plusieurs raisons
a été dévoyé de son
objectif tout d'abord il faut rappeler
que sous le mandat précédent
présidentiel précédent j'ai eu avec
d'autres collègues à connaître
évidemment de ses politiques et de ses
projets
je voudrais témoigner je crois que je ne
seraai pas démenti à cette tribune que
les moyens qui a une époque étaient
assez
ératique quand il étaient donnés à lpra
on ensuite été en terme budgétaire
sanctuarisé parce que nous le savions
pertinemment que les situations
internationales variaent et qu'il
fallait à tout prix permettre à cet
organisme auquel nous sommes attachés de
pouvoir mener les politiques
correctement nous avons aussi en
d'autres
cré la la Cour nationale du droit
d'asile je me souviens dans cet
hémicycle avoir défendu un certain
nombre de point de vue sur ce sujet là
donc l'architecture du dispositif était
en place mais aujourd'hui cette
architecture elle doit évoluer ét
insuffisante que se passe-t-il le
demandeur qui arrive sur notre
territoire avant d'obtenir la protection
que la France voudrait lui
accorder ou voir lui dire qu'il ne lui
accorde pas doit attendre dans un délai
moyen de 17 à 24 mois c'est à peu près
ça les demandes ont augmenté
régulièrement puisque en 2012 nous
avions 61
61468 demandeurs en 2013
66251 et en 2014 un peu mieux vous
l'avez dit monsieur le ministre mais
tout de même
demandeurs les stocks au même moment
pour 2012 sont de
24498 et pour 2013 de
3197 les admissions en 2012 sont de
10000 en 2013 de 11428 et en 2014 de
14512 si l'on fait la différence entre
les admissions et les refus on se rend
compte que le système produit à peu près
40000 débouté du droit d'asile chaque
année ceci est lié tout particulièrement
au fait que la procédure ét en longue et
bien des filières ou pas seulement des
filières utilise désormais utilise
toujours et utiliser utilise désormais
oui la procédure de demande d'asile
comme si elle était une procédure
d'immigration
et il est évident que cela ne peut pas
fonctionner alors le texte qui euh a été
soumis au
Sénat pouvait être vu en même temps que
le texte immigration ça n'a pas été le
choix qui a été fait à la fois qui peut
être possible parce qu'on distingue bien
les choses et qui en même temps est un
peu regrettable et je m'expliquerai
là-dessus qu' lorsque vous lorsque vous
avez une procédure qui génère 40000
déboutés du droit d'asile
et que ceci de fait réintègre si vous me
permettez cette
expression la clandestinité on a bien là
un point de contact avec le traitement
de l'immigration clandestine mais on ne
peut pas traiter de l'asile sans avoir
conscience de
cela alors le texte qui nous est soumis
c'est d'abord la retranscription de
trois
directives une que l'on que l'on aurait
dû déjà
intégré dans notre droit qui est la
directive qualification de 2011 ça
aurait dû être fait depuis le mois de
décembre
2013 et deux autres la directive accueil
qui touche particulièrement à deux
thématiques la vulnérabilité et l'accès
au marché du travail et la directive
procédure qui crée un certain nombre de
moyens pour essayer tenter de réduire
les délais d'instruction des demandes
d'asile je voudrais citer pour euh
l'exposé euh d'une part la création d'un
une procédure d'irrecevabilité ou de
clôture d'instruction des dossiers par
l'OFPRA qui n'existait pas jusqu'à
maintenant dans des conditions qui sont
parfaitement déterminées mais créer
aussi une procédure accéléré en
remplacement de la procédure dite
prioritaire qui permet là aussi de
traiter dans un délai bref de 5 semaines
les demandes qui paraissent à l'OFPRA
comme étant celles qui ont le peu de
chance le MO moins de chance
d'aboutir mais ce texte prévoit aussi de
renforcer les pouvoirs de l'OFPRA de
modifier son conseil d'administration et
singulièrement d'évoluer on peut le dire
ponctuellement sur les pays dit
d'origine sûre il fait que la CNDA doit
siéger décider pardon en 5 mois mais
qu'elle peut aussi siéger non seulement
en formation collégiale mais en juge
unique c'est une procédure qui est
contestée par un certain nombre de nos
collègues mais néanmoins cette procédure
par tout à fait pertinente à l'égard des
besoins de la nécessité de traiter une
fois de plus rapidement des dossiers
dont on sait que le destin ne sera pas
positif mais le droit des demandeurs est
réservé dans les deux cas puisque'à
chaque niveau de la procédure les
magistrat peuvent décider de confier le
sujet à la formation
collégiale et puis ce texte prévoit
aussi des ajustements de notre droit
français dans ce que l'on appelle les
Dublins et notamment dans l'application
de la directive Dublin 3 en réalité
l'objectif dans cette procédure là c'est
de pouvoir déterminer le plus rapidement
possible l'état d'origine du demandeur
pour pouvoir le renvoyer sa demande le
plus vite possible à cet état voilà la
réalité des choses il y a également un
autre point qui est important et qui
touche à l'hébergement l'hébergement
c'est un des sujets majeurs puisque nous
nous rendons compte et la Commission
s'est rendu compte
depuis longtemps déjà de la difficulté
dans laquelle se trouvent les CAD à la
fois occupé par des demandeurs qui dans
la procédure est en cours et à la fois
toujours occupé par des demandeurs qui
ont été déboutés mais c'est également
vrai qu'il est nécessaire compte tenu
des pressions migratoires plus de 50 %
des pressions sur deux régions
particulières que sont l'Île-de-France
et la région renalpe d'organiser les
choses de manière un peu plus directif
et de mettre en place ce schéma directif
de l'asile
c'est une chose positive que la
commission des lois bien sûr validé et
souhaite qu'elle soit maintenue malgré
je dois le dire un certain nombre
d'amendements qui visent à la
suppression de ce dispositif mais c'est
aussi plus de pouvoir donné à l'OFI dans
ce texte dans la gestion de
l'hébergement mais également dans la
capacité de pouvoir allouer ou pas un
certain nombre d'aidees en fonction de
cet
hébergement nous pouvons dire
sincèrement que sur la partie procédure
le la retranscription des directives et
les amendements qui ont été apportés par
la commission des Lois du Sénat après
que l'Assemblée nationale a examiné ce
texte vont plutôt dans le bon sens à
savoir assurer que la demande du
demandeur d'asile des demandeurs sera
bien traité dans un objectif de 9 mois 5
mois pour la CNDA nous souhaitons 3 mois
pour
l'OFPRA de manière à ce que
l'attractivité qui est aujourd'hui celle
de la durée à l'égard de ceux qui n'ont
pas qui ne sont pas
par dans le cadre de la protection de
l'asile ne soit plus un
argument plus la procédure sera rapide
naturellement dans le respect des droits
des uns et des autres il y a beaucoup de
choses encore dans le texte on verra ça
au cours du débat plus les information
comme quoi les choses vont vite
montreront qu'il n'y a pas d'intérêt
pour ceux qui utilisent cette procédure
à d'autres fins que l'asile d' d'emboîer
cette procédure je voudrais rappeler
également que au cours de nos
discussions nous nous sommes avons été
informés d'un relevé d'observation
provisoire de la Cour des
comptes et ce relevé d'observation
provisoire nous a interrogé à tel point
que j'ai sollicité la commission qu'elle
laisse un délai supplémentaire pour
pouvoir prendre connaissance de ce
document et éventuellement pouvoir
entendre la la Cour des
comptes malheureusement pour des raisons
de réglementation interne de la cour
court il n'a pas été possible
d'auditionner réellement le président et
surtout le président de la 4e chambre
néanmoins un entretien a pu avoir lieu
la présence du du président de la
commission des lois et nous savons
aujourd'hui que le rapport définitif de
la Cour des comptes sera communiqué
vraisemblablement à la fin du mois de
juin et nous nous aimerions connaître ou
savoir en tous les cas sur les arguments
qui ont été avancés à savoir que le coût
de l'asile c'est 2 milliards d'euros et
que le pourcentage des personnes
éloignées réellement des déboutés serait
de 1 % quelle était la réalité de ces
affirmations sincèrement je dois dire au
Sénat que ce soir nous n'avons pas la
réponse puisque la cour c'est nous a
indiquer qu'elle ne pouvait pas répondre
dans l'état que par ailleurs et je le
dis bien volontiers elle avait interrogé
un certain nombre de services dont elle
attendait encore la réponse mais c'est
un point sur lequel il conviendra de
revenir et de savoir précisément car
elle indique elle-même dans ce rapport
ce relevé provisoire de décision que le
système est embolisé qu'il ne fonctionne
pas et qu'il faut donc le
modifier mais nous avons estimé à la
commission des lois qu'on ne pouvait pas
modifier ce texte enfin modifier le
singulièrement la procédure et la rendre
certaine si nous ne trations pas à
l'instant le cas des déboutés du droit
d'asile il fallait impérativement
pouvoir fonctionner sur deux pieds il a
pas de volonté de polémique là-dessus il
y a simplement la volonté de constater
une réalité et d'essayer d'y apporter
une réponse car je pense sincèrement que
sur le fond j'espère en tous les cas que
nous poursuivons les mêmes objectifs et
cette réponse elle se trouve à travers
des amendements qui ont été
adoptés le premier qui consiste à ce que
lorsque la décision de l'OFPRA ou de la
Cour nationale du droit d'asile a un
caractère définitif et que la décision
de rejet en la circonstance
elle vaille également obligation de
quitter le territoire national
elle n'est pas là pour mettre de l'huile
sur le feu elle est simplement là la
Commission a estimé qu'on gagnerait du
temps si cette décision intervenait au
moment de la où la cour ou l'OFPRA se
prononce définitivement par rapport au
moment où le préfet prend le à
connaissance de la décision définitive
et prend lui-même cette obligation de
quitter le territoire national je crois
qu'il faut sur plan juridique on a bien
indiqué un certain nombre de précautions
dans le texte mais il faut dire aussi
que la possibilité de contester cet qtf
par le demandeur reste tout à fait
ouverte et quand ça le traitement qui
est fait de ce point particulier par le
demandeur qu'il soit dans le dans le
contexte clandestin comme on l'évoquait
tout à l'heure ou qu'il soit à la suite
du du rejet de sa demande paraît tout à
fait assuré et me paraît être assez
clair le deuxième point sur lequel nous
nous sommes engagés c'est de dire que
lorsqu'on avait fait le choix de la
procédure de l'asile on ne pouvait pas
si on était débouté aller sur un autre
titre de
séjour sauf circonstances particulières
avons-nous dit pourquoi une telle
décision simplement parce qu'il y a une
réalité la réalité elle est constatée et
partagée lorsque vous
êtes dans la procédure d'asile don vous
savez que vous ne l'aurez pas au bout
parce que ça n'est pas votre but dès que
l'on est député c'est l'idée d'aller sur
un autre titre de séjour pour tenter de
rester sur le territoire national c'est
ça la réalité et qu'à ce titre là on
fait des demandes nouvelles et on essaie
de tenir si vous me permettez cette
expression on essaie de profiter de la
circulaire du mois de novembre 2012 qui
au bout de 5 ans permet de rester sur le
territoire on essae beaucoup de choses
et on nourrit finalement l'ensemble du
dispositif on a considéré que sauf
circonstance particulières dès lors
qu'on avait choisi le principe de
l'asile on ne pouvait pas ensuite aller
sur un autre titre de
séjour enfin il a été
aussi décidé par la commission des lois
de faire droit à une proposition de
notre collègue Valérie lettard qui sur
la base de son rapport et de celui de
Monsieur Touren souhaitait que l'on
puisse dans le traitement des
déboutés créer des centres qui
permettent de prendre en charge c'est
débouté du d'asile pour les accompagner
finalement à l'éloignement et retourner
dans leur pays pays d'origine la
commission des lois a fait droit à
accepter bien volontiers cette
proposition pensant qu'elle était tout à
fait pertinente et puis quelques autres
points viennent conforter ces éléments
il s'agit tout
particulièrement du fait que il n'y ait
plus de d'inconditionnalité de
l'hébergement lorsque l'on est débouté
du droit d'asile on n pas de raison à
être absolument logé dès lors que on a
plus cette protection qu'on n'est plus
dans la procédure et nous avons enfin
essayé de trouver au global une
procédure qui se veut
équilibré certes elle peut-être discutée
certes elle sera discutée mais il
convient tout de même aussi de
considérer que il faut impérativement
que l'on envoie aussi des messages
clairs sur les souhaits que nous voulons
je pense sincèrement monsieur le
ministre je le dis à tous les collègues
qui sont ici que si nous ne prenons pas
des mesures qui fonctionnent sur les
deux piedsou sur les deux jambes sur ces
deux principes nous tuerons la procédure
d'asile et nous serons dans une nous
mettons dans une situation extrêmement
difficile qui nous permettra pas de
répondre rapidement ou suffisamment
rapidement à ceux qui ont besoin de
cette procédure et ce qui est l'honneur
de notre pays de leur accorder et je
crois que nous avons essayé de
rééquilibrer ce texte avec cet espritl
même si parfois il peut paraître un peu
rigoureux il me paraît suffisamment
crédible pour nous permettre et
permettre collectivement de traiter
parfaitement et correctement ce qui
mérite la protection de la France merci
je vais suspendre la séance elle sera
reprise à
21h45 pour la suite d'examen du projet
de loi relatif à la réforme de l'asile
la séance est suspendue la séance est
reprise nous reprenons la suite de la
discussion du projet de loi adopté par
l'Assemblée nationale après engagement
de la procédure accélérée relative à la
réforme de
l'asile dans la suite de la discussion
générale la parole est à Monsieur Pierre
Yve
Colomba pour 7
minutes
vous avez la parole chers
collègues
merci madame la Présidente mon le
ministre chers
collègues l'essentiel ayant été dit par
mes
prédécesseurs je m'en tiendrai à
quelques points qui me paraissent les
plus important le premier c'est que le
droit d'asile consacré par la Première
République française constitue avec les
droits de l'homme qu'il vient compléter
une sorte de marque de
fabrique passez-moi l'expression qui
engage la France la France qui entend
rester fidèle à ses principes fondateurs
qu'elle ne l'est pas toujours fait et
pas seulement sous des régimes non
républicains n change rien aujourd'hui
cependant l'exercice effectif de ce
droit d'hospitalité est menacé de deux
manières d'ailleurs
lié d'abord l'explosion d'une nombre des
bénéficiaires potentiels ce qui en
change la nature
ensuite les délais de procédure qui
finissent par en neutraliser
l'efficacité et qui sont source de
souffrance inutile pour les intéressés
l'article 120 de la Constitution de l'an
1 proclame que le peuple français donne
asile aux étrangers bannis de leur pays
pour la cause de la liberté il le refuse
au
Tiran sans s'attarder sur le sort
souvent réservé par la douce France au
tirant d'échu qui pose un autre problème
constatons la difficulté de plus en plus
grande aujourd'hui à distinguer les
martyres de la liberté des victimes
impuissantes de l'incurie de la
corruption des régimes policiers qui ne
peutvent faire autrement que subir ou
fuir il ne s'agit plus de répondre à
l'attente d'individus voire de groupes
ciblés ponctuellement par la persécution
mais de foules entières parfois
transformé cyniquement en armes de
guerre par leur bourreaux voir le cas
libien le projet de loi je le constate
contourne cet aspect du
problème ce qui est fâcheux pour se
libérer ce que je pour se limiter ce que
je comprends à améliorer à
l'amélioration de la procédure de
traitement des dossiers de demande
d'asile afin de rendre plus de les
rendre plus conformes à son objet la
durée moyenne totale d'une procédure
d'examen de en première demande d'asile
par l'OFPRA suivi d'un recours à la CNDA
est estimé on le sait à 19 mois et demi
dans le cas où après un premier rejet
définitif le demandeur d'asile le
demandeur sollicite un réexamen de sa
demande et qu'elle est suivie d'un
recours le délai passe à 2 ans 7 mois
environ si comme le relève la Cour des
comptes 75 % des demandes d'asile sont
rejetées annuellement en moyenne cela
signifie que ces demandes étaient
infondées et qu'on assiste à un
véritable détournement de la procédure
de demande d'asile ce qui se paye on l'a
dit en coût financier et en coût humain
coût financier depuis 2008 les dépenses
du programme 303 sont passées de 340
millions d'euros à plus de 600 millions
d'euros en 2014 selon les estimations
une réduction de 3 mois de délai
d'instruction de l'U pra et de 6 mois de
ceux de jugement de la CNDA permettrait
d'économiser de l'ordre de 88 millions
d'euros de dépenses d'hébergement et
d'allocation coout humain lorsqu'une
famille de demandeur d'asile s'est
installé pendant 2 années sur le
territoire français que les parents
parfois travaillent que les enfants sont
scolarisés parlent français comment
renvoyer cette famille d'où elle vient
sans y regarder à trois fois pour le RDS
donc le projet de loi va dans le bon
sens même s'il répond plus à l'urgence
qu'à un traitement de fond du problème
nous souscrivons à la fois à la
simplification à la réduction des délais
d'examen et de réexamen des demandes
devant l'OFPRA comme devant la CNDA à
l'établissement d'une liste pays sûr
afin de rationaliser les flux et en même
temps donc au renforcement des garanties
procédural conforme à la directive à la
directive européenne droit au maintien
sur le territoire à tous les demandeurs
d'asile tenue d'un entretien personnel
présence d'un avocat lors de cet
entretien prise en compte système tique
de la vulnérabilité des demandeurs
possibilité du hclos pour les audiences
devant la Cour reste évidemment le plus
difficile comme je l'ai indiqué la
gestion des flux migratoires à l'échelle
européenne l'exécution effective de
l'obligation de quitter le territoire
français qui selon la Cour des comptes
n'est guerre exécuté enfin monsur
ministre tout à l'heure nous a dit que
ça allait mieux enfin et cetera mais je
pense que tout le monde s'accordera pour
dire qu'il y a encore des des marges de
de de progrès alors des remèdes sont
proposés qu'une décision définitive de
rejet de la demande vaille obligation de
quitter le territoire français qu'un
étranger débouté ne puisse être autorisé
à demeurer sur le territoire à un autre
titre ils ont la logique pour eux mais
ne sont pas forcément conformes au
principe international du droit et une
vie familiale au principe humanitaires
renvoyer quelqu'un sinon des familles
entières en enfer mais même s'ils n'ont
aucun droit à en sortir et rien moins
qu'unodin et je ne dis rien des
injonctions contradictoires de l'ordre
médiatique reprochant au gouvernement
dans un même mouvement sa passivité
devant l'immigration illégale et son
insensibilité aux drames humains
qu'engendr nécessairement la lutte
contre elle la rationalisation proposée
par ce projet de loi est souhaitable
personne n'en doute mais beaucoup reste
à faire personne n'en doute non plus la
première preuve de la volonté du
gouvernement d'avancer sera qu'il s'en
donne effectivement et sur la durée les
moyens financiers ce qui a constaté la
sous-budgétisation constante de la
mission immigration asile intégration
est loin d'avoir été le cas jusqu'ici
les mouvements de Menton atteignent
rarement le
porte-monnaie les membres du
RDSE ne s'opposeront pas à l'adoption du
présent projet de loi ils attendront
cependant l'issue définitive de la
discussion notamment celle des
amendements pour déterminer s'ils
pourront passer alors jusqu'à apobation
je vous remercie merci chers collègues
la parole est à Monsieur Stéphane Ravier
pour 3
minutes
bonsoir madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues mon temps
de parole esttant limité je n'irai pas
par quatre chemins le projet de loi qui
nous est soumis aujourd'hui est néfaste
pour notre pays ce texte ne va faire que
renforcer encore l'appel d'air permanent
qui est le régime de l'asile en France
en donnant au demandeurs toujours plus
de moyens de se maintenir sur notre sol
alors même que celui-ci est plus que
saturé d'immigration la majorité
sénatoriale a voulu reporter l'examen du
texte après la fuite d'un document
interne de la Cour des comptes qui
dénonce un système au bord de l'embolie
qui n'est pas soutenable à cour terme et
qui forme tout simplement la principale
source d'arrivée d'immigrants
clandestins en France hélas pour les
Français l'opposition de l'UMP à son
projet de loi n'est que du théâtre la
remarquable prestation de notre collègue
Roger carouci en est la parfaite
illustration puisque ce texte est la
transposition fidèle de plusieurs
directives européennes que la France est
obligée de transposer sans délai des
directives que les députés européen de
l'UMP ont voté au Parlement européen de
plus les demandes d'asile ont doublé
sous le mandat de Nicolas Sarkozi pour
atteindre 66000 cas pour la seule année
2013 ce ce seul chiffre nous montre
l'ampleur du scandale d'une politique
qui a été dévoyée de sa finalité
première pour devenir aujourd'hui
principalement une filière
migratoire sur les quelques 66000
demandes d'asile annuel les 3is/4s sont
finalement rejetés plus de 95 % des
déboutés se maintiennent sans droit ni
titrre sur notre territoire je cite là
encore la Cour des comptes tant que la
question de l'organisation systématique
et rapide de leur retour ne sera pas
réglé le système ne pourra fonctionner
correctement l'organisation systématique
et et rapide du retour voilà un point
monsieur le ministre que vous avez
évoqué dans votre intervention de façon
très très discrète le même la même Cour
considère que l'asile représente un coût
direct de 2 milliards d'euros par an à
savoir 1 milliard pour les demandeur
d'asile et 1 milliard pour les déboutés
qui restent illégalement en France et
c'est sans compter les coûts direct
divers pour les Français je pense par
exemple à la hausse des dépenses de
sécurité publique et privée devenu
nécessaire dans certaines zones habitées
par les faux réfugiés il est beaucoup
question CCI de République de
républicains mais comment oser parler de
République d'État de droit quand on ne
fait que laisser faire laisser passer et
entériner le fait accompli un peu
partout en France nos compatriotes les
plus modestes souffre de votre laxisme
et comble de l'ironie la petite minorité
des vrais demandeurs d'asile souffre
aussi car à vouloir accueillir tout le
monde sans discernement nous n'avons
plus les moyens de les héberger
dignement alors qu'il le mérite je
rejoint en ça le constat de notre
collègue Roger carouti enfin ces vrais
demandeurs d'asile vont immanquablement
souffrir de suspicion légitime que crée
chez les Français votre laxisme vous
faites mine de crier pas d'amalgame mais
vous faites tout pour en créer la gauche
au pouvoir comme l'UMP avant elle est
donc incapable de faire respecter la loi
républicaine et la cour et la cour
pointe même une forme de renoncement
dans certaines préfectures à cause de
l'absence de directive CLA du
gouvernement en conclusion ce texte
véritable machine à régulariser les
clandestins est d'autant plus néfaste
qu'il semble déconnecté du monde où nous
vivons qui connaît des arrivée massive
quotidienne de clandestin sur les
rivages de ce qu'un romancier devenu
visionnaire a a qualifié de cand desins
et un monde qui subit aussi des
persécutions de masse dans des pays où
se déroule un véritable génocide des
chrétiens d'Orient en une phrase
qu'avons-nous à proposer à ces millions
de réfugiés potentiels elle est là
l'urgence dans un dans une véritable
politique étrangère indépendante et
certainement pas dans le vote de ce
texte qui achève de transformer notre
pays en
passoir la parole est à Madame lettard
Valérie
lettard pour 12
minutes
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président de la
commission des lois messieurs les
rapporteurs mes chers collègues le
projet de loi relatif à la réforme de
l'asile est bien sûr un texte très
important à la fois chargé de symbole et
décisif pour que notre pays perpétue la
tradiction la tradition d'acc et
d'intégration inscrite dans son histoire
depuis la Révolution française dans le
contexte humain et face à une actualité
extrêmement sensible que monsieur le
ministre vient de nous rappeler nous
devons faire preuve de
responsabilité car un constat s'impose à
nous notre dispositif actuel de l'asile
au fil du temps a été dévoyé en
difficulté pour accueillir dans de
bonnes conditions ce qui justifierait de
l'être et sbolisé par des demandes qui
ne relèvent pas de l'asile mais plutôt
d'une immigration économique de la
pauvreté et donc d'un autre cadre que
celui de la Convention de Genève le 28
novembre 2013 j'avais rendu au ministre
de l'intérieur avec mon collègue
Jean-Louis Touren un rapport sur la
réforme de l'asile qui synthétisait les
conclusions de la concertation que nous
avions mené avec l'ensemble des acteurs
quotidiens de l'asile depuis lors
j'attendais avec impatience que nous
puissions la débattre au Parlement et ça
y est nous y sommes
les médias ont ces dernières semaines
fait leur une sur l'Europe assiégée et
bientôt envahie par les vagues de
migrant venus du sud quelquefois à
l'excès mais ce qui est certain c'est
qu'au regard de cette détresse il y a
urgence à traiter non seulement de la
question de l'accueil des demandeurs
d'asile mais bien plus globalement de la
réponse de l'Europe dans son ensemble
que dans la réponse à laquelle l'Europe
dans son ensemble compte apporter aux
immenses problèmes des pays qui sont à
sa porte lorsque Jean-Louis borlot nous
interpelle sur la situation de l'Afrique
continent d'un milliard d'habitants où
seul 180 millions de personnes ont
aujourd'hui accès à l'énergie mais ou
plus de 700 millions de portables
permettent de savoir tout ce qui se
passe ailleurs lorsque outre les
conflits les dérèglements climatiques
l'avancée du désert la déforestation la
sécheresse et la baisse des capacités
agricole comment pouvons-nous penser que
ce qui se passe en Afrique n'est pas
notre problème vous avez monsieur le
ministre souligné récemment la nécessité
de renforcer les coopérations avec les
pays de départ je ne peux qu'approuver
cette intention nous voyons bien
aujourd'hui que le plan d'action en 10
points adopté le 20 avril dernier par le
Conseil conjoint des ministres des
Affaires étrangères et de l'Intérieur ne
suffira pas à faire face à cette
situation de crise détruire les
embarcation des passeurs est certes
nécessaire mais donnera pas seul la
solution dans le même temps pouvons-nous
garder en tête que même si le nombre de
demandeurs d'asile a augmenté de 44 % en
2014 du fait des crises politique en
Syrie et en Irak il y a eu 626000
demandeurs qui ont frappé à la porte
d'une Europe de plus de 511 millions
d'habitants soit en moyenne 1,2
demandeurs d'asile par milliers
d'habitants mais il est vrai que cette
demande s'est concentrée sur quelques
pays seulement à commencer par
l'Allemagne la Suède l'Italie et la
France je souhaite d'ailleurs comme
nombre de mes collègues monsieur le
ministre que notre pays impulse des
actions nouvelles et soit moteur au sein
de l'Europe pour renforcer sa politique
de développement et améliorer le
fonctionnement de la politique
européenne de l'asile car nous le savons
c'est à ce niveau que tout se joue nous
nous rejoignons tous sur le fait que la
question de l'asile demande à être
dissocie de la question de notre
politique de l'immigration mais que
cette cette réforme bien sûr doit être
complétée comme vous l'avez rappelé
monsieur le ministre par une nécessaire
réforme de notre notre politique
d'immigration notre pays a besoin comme
ses voisins d'être attractif pour
accueillir une immigration
professionnelle en particulier dans les
secteurs où existent des besoins non
satisfaits nous devons pouvoir attirer
des talents et leur donner envie de
s'installer en France à l'image de ce
que pratique un pays comme le Canada
nous devons aussi prendre notre part de
l'immigration de la pauvreté mais nous
devons le faire d'une manière choisie et
non subi comme c'est le cas aujourd'hui
réfléchi et contrôlé avec des pouvoirs
afin de de pouvoir offrir à ces migrants
une vie décente et la possibilité de
s'intégrer socialement et
professionnellement trop souvent nos
formations politiques ont préféré
esquiver cette question sensible le vote
extrême nous rappelle avec force que nos
concitoyens attendent des réponses qui
ne soi ni l'angélisme de la bonne
conscience ni le simplisme du tous
dehors le projet de loi réforme la
politique de l'asile en transposant le
paquet asile composé de trois directives
qualification procédure et accueil que
nous devons avoir intégré à notre
législation nationale avant le 20
juillet 2015 je ne rappellerai pas leur
contenu le rapporteur l'a fait et en
tout cas on a rappelé l'esprit
excellemment la philosophie des règles
du régime d'asile européen commun repose
sur un équilibre entre des procédures
efficaces pour un traitement rapide des
dossiers et des garanties renforcées
pour les demandeurs et les personnes
obtenant la
protection le projet de loi doit nous
permettre de franchir une étape
importante en simplifiant la procédure
d'examen du droit d'asile à chaque étape
du parcours du demandeur en supprimant
la domiciliation en fixant des délais
contraignants pour l'examen de la
demande par l'Office français de
protection des réfugiés et apatrid puis
par la CNDA en organisant un hébergement
directif et l'accompagnement social et
administratif du demandeur en précisant
clairement les procédures de clôture
d'irrecevabilité de retrait et de
réexamen des dossiers par l'OFPRA en
permettant un examen au procédure
accélérées des dossiers manifestement
infondés ou prioritaires en instaurant
la possibilité du juge unique pour les
recours devant la CNDA nous devrions
pouvoir accélérer le traitement des
demandes et réduire de 2 ans environ en
moyenne et à 9 mois donc leur délai
d'examen cette réduction des délais est
impérative pour deux raisons d'abord
elle évitera que la procédure ne soit
détourné de son objet par des personnes
y voyant le moyen de se maintenir
longtemps sur le territoire français et
cela devrait décourager certaines
filières mafieuses elle permettra
d'accueillir par ailleurs rapidement les
personnes qui doivent être protégé car
elles sont menacées dans leur intégrité
ce qui est aujourd'hui de moins en moins
le cas le projet de loi permet aussi
d'intégrer des garanties supplémentaires
accordé au demandeur la possibilité de
se faire accompagner lors de l'entretien
de l'OFPRA l'enregistrement de
l'entretien le caractère suspensif du du
recours jusqu'à la fin de la procédure
et enfin la prise en compte de la
vulnérabilité la réforme apporte
également des simplifications bienvenu
la réaffirmation de l'indépendance de
l'OFPRA la création de mission
déconcentré de l'OFPRA dans les
territoires qui permettent de faire face
efficacement à des afflus soudains de
demande la suppression de la condition
préalable de domiciliation la
désignation de l'OFI comme responsable
du dispositif d'accueil du demandeur
lors de son examen l'Assemblée nationale
a infléchi le texte afin d'y introduire
notamment la prise en compte des violen
fait aux femmes une révision régulière
de la liste des pays d'origine sûre ou
encore l'ouverture à la parité du
conseil d'administration de l'OFPRA ou
l'assouplissement de certains délaiis
une place faite aux associations de
défense des droits de l'homme des femmes
ou des enfants bref toute une série de
mesures qui sont venu compléter le
travail du gouvernement globalement le
projet de loi tel qui nous a été soumis
après son passage à l'Assemblée reprend
assez fidèlement les préconisation de
simplification et de réorganisation de
notre rapport de novembre 2013 à une ex
tion notable prêt ce texte a choisi de
ne pas traiter de la question des
déboutés or cette question est centrale
monsieur le ministre si l'on veut donner
à la réforme de l'asile tout son sens
tout en ayant entendu les les
explications que vous nous avez donné
tout à l'heure car en effet si en 2014
28 % des
64811 demandeurs d'asile ont été
satisfaites cela signifie que dans 72 %
des cas les personnes ont été déboutées
or un des points sur le qu notre rapport
avait mis l'accent était la nécessité
que les demandeurs déboutés n'entrent
pas comme c'est le cas actuellement dans
la clandestinité hébergé dans le
dispositif d'ébergement d'urgence ou par
des marchands de sommeil et très souvent
exploité dans des filières qui abusent
de leur situation de précarité mais
qu'au contraire on puisse les diriger
vers des structures spécifiques des
centres dédiés où ils seraient assignés
à résidence certes mais où leur
situation ferait l'objet si nécessaire
d'un dernier examen et une fois
l'obligation de quitter le territoire
français délivré si ça devait être le
cas leur serait assurer et la
préparation psychologique et surtout
matérielle au retour plutôt
qu'effectivement ignorer le sujet et les
renvoyer à leur situation d'immigrer en
situation irrégulière sans se volet la
réforme de l'asile n'est pas complète et
je me réjouis que la commission des lois
est adopté mon amendement proposant la
possibilité de mettre en place ces
centres dédiés au déboutés en ajoutant
au texte un article 14 bis permettez-moi
en abordant les travaux en commission
des lois de notre assemblée de saluer la
très grande qualité du travail de
réécriture proposé par le rapporteur de
votre commission notre collègue François
Noël buffet plus fluide plus précise
plus ramassée la rédaction de nombreux
articles a beaucoup gagné après l'examen
du texte en commission enfin je voudrais
terminer mon propos en abordant deux
points importants sur lesquels nous
aurons l'occasion de revenir pendant
dans l'examen des
amendements une partie d'abord une
partie de la majorité sénatoriale
réagissant à la publication d'un article
du Figaro sur les éléments d'un rapport
à venir de la Cour des comptes qui
reprenait pourtant des chiffres déjà
connus par ailleurs avait souhaité
durcir le texte qui pourrait sortir du
Sénat et une de ces propositions qui est
plutôt forte que vous avez rappelé tout
à l'heure monsieur le rapporteur qui est
toujours présente dans ce
texte il s'agit de la décision de
l'OFPRA et de la CNDA qui vaudrait au
qtf obligation de quitter le territoire
français sur ce point précis il me
semble que ce serait une erreur de la
laisser perdurer pourquoi tout
simplement parce que je suis convaincu
que les décisions d'un agent de l'OFPRA
ou d'un juge de la CNDA seraiit brouillé
si elle devait être assimilée à une
mesure de police administrative qui
relève d'une autre autorité nous aurons
je pense l'occasion d'en débattre tout à
enfin plus tard dans le cadre de la
séance et de l'examen des amendements et
j'espère que nous aurons la possibilité
de rentrer dans le détail il y a
beaucoup d'amendements à faire comment
d'arguments à faire valoir sur cet
amendement il reste également me
semble-t-il une dernière étape à
franchir si nous voulons adapter le
processus d'examen de l'asile à la fois
à notre nouvelle organisation des
territoires il y a des entrées
inégalement réparties selon les régions
c'est la territorialisation de l'OFPRA
afin que des antennes de cet organisme
puisse éventuellement être créé là où
existe une forte demande je regrette que
la commission des finances ait prononcé
l'article 40 sur cet amendement 43
rectifié bis et donc la sortie du débat
parlementaire sauf à ce que le
gouvernement monsieur le ministre le
réintroduise s'il juge que cela mérite
d'être expérimenté car il me semble que
sur la question de l'article 40 et bien
on voit bien que je pense qu'il y aurait
plus d'économie et d'avantage à trouver
à maintenir une territorialisation
expérimentée qu'à ne pas le faire quand
on sait l'impact de mission foraine
répéter par exemple en terme budgétaire
ou que l'on connaît par ailleurs le coût
du déplacement des demandeurs d'asile
qui vont massivement devoir se rendre à
Paris et qui s'y reprendront à plusieurs
fois et quand on fait l'équation
budgétaire on se rend compte que c'est
plutôt un plus qu'un moins rendre notre
dispositif plus souple plus proche des
territoires plus opérant tout en
réduisant les délais excessifs qui
nuisent à sa lisibilité c'est je le
crois la meilleure manière de réussir la
réforme de l'asile et cette exigence de
réussite nous oblige car elle impactera
directement les milliers de demandeurs
qui se présentent à nos frontières
chaque année et tous les acteurs
quotidiens de l'asile travailleurs
sociaux officiers de protection agents
des préfectures juges qui travaillent
aujourd'hui dans des conditions
difficiles et méritent d'être soutenu
vous l'avez rappelé monsieur carucci et
ce sera le dernier aspect il faudra
effectivement être attentif et plus
qu'attentif soueux soucieux que les
bénéficiaires du statut puissent être
pris en compte dans de meilleures
conditions en conclu conusion à cette
intervention je voudrais citer ces
quelques lignes de gens dormaissant les
français s'interrogent sans cesse
qu'est-ce qu'être français c'est qu'il y
a au cœur de la France quelque chose qui
la dépasse elle n'est pas seulement une
contradiction et une diversité elle
regarde aussi sans cesse par-dessus son
épaule vers les autres vers le monde
autour d'elle plus qu'aucune nation au
monde la France est hanté par une
aspiration à l'universel Maler assuré
que la France n'était jamais autant la
France qu'en s'adressant aux autres
nations c'est une tâche difficile de
vouloir rester soi-même tout en essayant
de s'ouvrir aux autres Français encore
un effort pour être un peu plus que
français et pour faire de la France ce
qu'elle a toujours rêvé d'être un modèle
d'humanité et de diversité un modèle
d'humanité et de diversité voilà ce que
je souhaite que devienne notre système
de l'asile je vous remercie merci la
parole est à Monsieur Jean
lecte
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers
collègues protéger les combattants de la
liberté protéger les victimes du
totalitarisme c'est une tradition
française marqué d'abord dans cette
Constitution de 1793 puis repris en
particulier dans le préambule de celle
de 1946 enfin établi au niveau
internationale par la Convention de
Genève de juillet 1951 donc dans notre
pays il y a deux bases pour ce cet asile
cette protection des combattants de la
liberté une base constitutionnelle et
une base conventionnelle affirmer
l'universalité du droit des idées de
l'égalité des hommes c'est essentiel et
c'est une valeur pour notre pays et
c'est refuser le repli sur soi
reconnaître aux combattants de la
liberté aux personnes persécutées le
fait qu'elles sont nos frères humains et
qu'elles mérite notre protection c'est
notre devoir on ne peut pas affirmer de
valeurs sans être solidaire de ceux qui
les partagent sans être solidaire de
ceux qui combattent au nom de la liberté
de l'humanisme affirmer l'universalité
de l'humain face à la barbarie c'est au
cœur de notre récit national renforcer
le droit d'asile ce n'est pas un poids
mais l'affirmation de notre identité et
de nos valeurs et c'est ainsi je crois
qu'il faut aborder ce débat et de ce
point de vue je dois dire que je suis
c'est avec une grande fierté que que je
l'aborde car dans ce projet il y a trois
points essentiels d'abord nous affirmons
que donner plus de garanties aux
demandeurs et respecter leurs droits
c'est ai améliorer l'efficacité de notre
système deuxièmement la France veut
réaffirmer sa disposition à respecter
les demandeurs en améliorant les délais
pour leur donner des réponses rapides
parce qu'ils en ont besoin enfin ce
projet donne à la France les moyens de
prendre les dispositions nécessaires et
des positions en Europe pour répondre au
défis des tragédies que nous devons
malheureusement constater tous les jours
en Méditerranée alors de ce point de vue
vous connaissez la théorie de de l'appel
d'air alors il y a certains
gouvernements avant qui facee à l'appel
d'air ont bouché le système et c'est ce
dont nous avons c'est c'est ce dont nous
avons hérité un système totalement
embolisé qui conduit finalement à parier
que en bouchant le système on va
dissuader les demandeurs et comme on
dissuade les demandeurs il y en aura
plus alors on voit à quoi ça conduit les
vrais demandeurs ils vont ailleurs et
ceux qui viennent ici ils utilisent le
système pour finalement obtenir un droit
de rester sur le territoire le temps que
la procédure longue ne soit pas arrivée
à sa fin et tout ça à un coût à peu près
60 à 70 millions d'euros par mois soit
finalement le
budget annuel de l'OF pra alors réduire
les délais réduire les délais c'est
essentiel
pour sortir de cette espèce de théorie
du boucher l'appel d'air qui finalement
a conduit à la situation actuelle de
d'embolie totale du système et nous
affirmons par ce projet notre volonté
de devenir à nouveau attractif car ça a
été dit en Europe entre 2012 et 2014 il
y a eu un doublement de la demande en
Allemagne plus qu'un doublement et la
France ça stagne alors la question de
notre attractivité elle est centrale
elle est centrale parce que
finalement si on se dit oui
l'immigration aujourd'hui c'est provoque
des tensions en France donc finalement
le fait qu'on soit pas trop attractif
bah ça va c'est pas trop dérangeant mais
non l'attractivité c'est une preuve de
santé l'attractivité c'est une preuve
que nous soyons que nous sommes fidèle à
nos valeurs et l'attractivité c'est
aussi affirmer l'universalité de nos
valeurs plutôt que le replilis sur soi
et c'est cela que le projet porte alors
je crois que à cette étape de la de la
discussion comme d'autres auparavant il
est effectivement indispensable de bien
séparer l'asile et l'immigration et donc
de l'espèce d'essayer de Fissel les
intersections intersection d'une part à
l'entrée et je l'ai dit si on sait que
le système euh va finalement donner
avoir des procédures qui durent 2 ans
bah c'est pas ceux qui veulent vraiment
une protection rapide pour pouvoir
s'insérer et finalement continuer avoir
le droit de vivre mais c'est ceux qui
ont besoin de pouvoir avoir un moyen de
rester longtemps sur le territoire alors
que finalement ils savent bien que leur
protection ne sera pas accordé et donc
il faut faire en sorte que à l'entrée il
y ait des procédures qui soient rapides
d'accueil et que les délais soient
courts soient courts pour la sortie du
système au moment où que les protections
soient rapidement donné que les délais
parce que on parle des déboutés mais les
déboutés c'est pas simplement les TF les
déboutés c'est être capable de dire à
quelqu'un qui demande en quelques mois
oui ou non c'est quand même plus simple
de lui demander de partir s'il est là
depuis 4 mois que s'il est là depuis 3
ans et donc à partir de là traiter les
déboutill du droit d'asile c'est d'abord
traiter les délais faire en sorte d'être
capable de répondre vite en respectant
donc le droit à celui qui demande d'être
capable d'avoir une réponse rapide donc
plutôt que de se poser d'abord la
question des otf ou poser penser que
c'est vraiment la réponse à tout non la
première manière de traiter les déboutés
du droit d'asile c'est que les réponses
arrivent vite et que les délais soient
courts et c'est l'objet de ce projet
alors depuis 2 ans
finalement le le le le le système a été
amélioré j'allais dire au
niveau du travail de la mobilisation des
agents à l'OFPRA à la CNDA de manière à
ce que finalement il y ait plus de
décision qui soit rendu tous les ans de
manière à essayer de désemboiliser le
système mais aujourd'hui il faut aller
plus loin il faut aller plus loin parce
que pour aller plus euh pour continuer à
améliorer les délais on peut pas
simplement se contenter de changer et
d'améliorer la productivité des agents
et la rapidité des décisions à la CNDA
mais il faut modifier les lois pour
affirmer plus de garantiese au moment de
l'OFPRA et au moment de de de la
procédure à l'OFPRA et faire en sorte
que la CNDA puisse se prononcer
rapidement au moment dans les procédures
accélérées je donne par exemple un un
simple exemple en 2011 43 % des
protections étaient données par leofpra
en 2014 60 % cette différence de 17 %
c'est autant de personnes qui sont des
demandeurs légitimes qui ne vont pas
attendre l'année ou les 2 ans de la
procédure à la CNDA pour se voir
reconnaître une protection et c'est
comme ça qu'on combat les délais et
c'est comme ça que ça a été combattu au
cours des deux dernières années mais
maintenant pour aller plus loin il y a
besoin il y a besoin d'une d'une loi
alors cette loi nous l'avons dit ça a
été répété déjà par plusieurs d'entre
nous et d'abord présenté par le monsieur
le le ministre au moment de la procédure
offpra donner plus de garanties au
demandeurs faire en sorte que les
conditions d'accueil soient meilleures
pour tous les demandeurs améliorer les
droits et les délais des demandeurs et
en particulier en en permettant la
présence d'un hier lors de l'entretien à
l'OFPRA faire en sorte que la CND a une
procédure spécifique de manière à aller
vite au moment des procédure accéléré et
enfin un hébergement directif de manière
à répartir l'accueil sur l'ensemble du
territoire ce sont les principales
dispositions de ce texte ces
dispositions qui doivent aller bien
entendu en France métropolitaine mais
qui finalement nous sommes un pays avec
des territoires d'outrmire d'autres des
territoires qui sont en conflit en
contact avec d'autres situations
géopolitiques que la situation
européenne et cela rend pour la France
l'ensemble de ce dispositif qui doit
être cohérent avec le dispositif
européen compliqué mais c'est pour ça
aussi que nous avons des dispositions
pour l'outrem et des interrogations sur
l'outrem alors sur les délais il y a
bien entendu des défis parce que avoir
les 60 65000 demandes par an que nous
avons aujourd'hui avec les moyens qui
ont été donnés à l'OFPRA lors de la
dernière loi de finance nous savons que
ça pourrait tenir nous savons que ça
peut tenir maintenant si nous sommes
soumis à une sollicitation égale à celle
de l'Allemagne l'interrogation reste
entière et il faudra à cette à ce
moment-là augmenter les moyens parce que
bien entendu face à un doublement de la
demande d'asile en Allemagne c'est par
par centaine que l'équivalent de l'OFPRA
a dû recruter pour faire face aux
besoins enfin sur ce qui concerne un
autre défi c'est les procédures
d'accueil en préfecture qui qui sont
chargés qui sont aussi maintenant
transmises au guichet unique avec géré
en en commun avec
l'OFI ce sont des délais très importants
aujourd'hui et je crois que ça sera l'un
des principals défis de la mise en œuvre
de cette de cette réforme
alors tout tout ceci nous devons le
faire d'ici juillet parce que cela déjà
été dit plusieurs fois ce texte a aussi
vocation à transposer les directives
qualification procédure et accueil mais
pour faire en sorte que c'est c'est
important que ce soit vite parce que
l'Europe la France a besoin d'être en
Europe crédible et clair pour pouvoir
faire en sorte que l'Europe modifie ses
dispositifs d'asile parce que
aujourd'hui les drames en Méditerranée
l'immigration économique nous en avons
parler mais nous savons bien aussi qu'il
y a des gens qui sont à la recherche
d'une protecture internationale qui
viennent d'Irak de Syrie de Libye est-il
logique que ces gens ces êtres humains
qui ont besoin aujourd'hui d'une
protection on leur demande de risquer
leur vie pour avoir ensuite le droit de
demander une protection est-ce que c'est
vraiment ce qu'on veut je rappelle qu'en
Jordanie au Liban en Turquie ce sont par
million que nous avons euh des réfugiés
euh syriens quen Tunisie en Égypte nous
en avons beaucoup euh de Libye et de ce
point de vue-là je crois qu'il faut que
l'Europe soit totalement responsabilisée
pour euh être capable de faire face
ensemble à ce défi et de ce point de
vue-là je voudrais rendre hommage au
travail de l'OFPRA et des consulats qui
examinent sur place dans un certain
nombre de pays les demandes d'asile qui
sont qui arrivent déposées sans que les
gens soient déjà ici mais parce que la
protection et notre devoir de protection
il doit s'exercer aussi hors de France
pour pourquoi demander aux gens de
risquer leur vie pour leur accorder une
protection alors euh cette révision
Dublin que aujourd'hui devient
indispensable nous n'osons plus demander
à l'Italie de respecter Dublin compte
tenu des circonstances même si nous
savons bien qu'une bonne part de ceux
qui arrivent en Italie continuent
ensuite vers l'Allemagne la Suède nous
savons aussi qu'il a besoin de temps
parce que des pays comme la Bulgarie ou
la Hongrie n'en peuvent plus nont plus
les moyens il est important de répartir
la charge de la même manière que nous
devons répartir l'accueil sur le
territoire français sur l'ensemble du
territoire européen alors en conclusion
mes chers collègues je voudrais dire que
le groupe socialiste bien entendu sera
d'abord salue l'état d'esprit dans
lequel finalement le rapporteur a a
travaillé sur le texte même si sur les
questions d'qtf nous y reviendrons parce
que finalement c'est un point dur c'est
un point dur pour nous en terme de
principe aussi parce que vous essayez de
construire un modèle allemand mais pas
jusqu'au bout et ce sera ce n'est pas
efficace nous y reviendrons dans les
dans les deres parce que ce n'est pas la
même chose et finalement en terme de
reconduite à la frontière si on regarde
les choses on s'en sort mieux pro toute
proportion gardé que nos que nos que que
que nos partenaires européens mais nous
reviendrons de de ce point de vue dans
ce débat
alors tous fiers de ce projet monsieur
le ministre de son esprit de la manière
dont il a été travaillé à l'Assemblée
nationale nous rendons hommage au
rapporteurs mais nous serons très
sensibles et très vigilant sur des
points durs de principe qui seraiit
susceptible de dénaturer le texte et de
faire en sorte que le travail du Sénat
sera balayé et ces pointsl nous
l'exprimerons dans le dans le débat
général je vous
remercie merci la parole est à Madame
ester
Benbassa madame la présidente monsieur
le ministre monsieur le président de la
commission des lois monsieur le
rapporteur mes chers collègues ce projet
de loi de réforme de l'asile nous étions
nombreux à en espérer beaucoup ma
déception n'année que plus grande mes
chers collègues quand je vois dans
quelles conditions il a été examiné
notre commission des lois n'a pu
travailler sereinement pour des raisons
que je soupçonne d'être plutôt
politicienne nous allons examiner un
texte capital par petitbout ce lundi
soir puis lundi prochain ce PGL qui
devait être une expression privilégé de
l'humanisme fondant notre démocratie
valait mieux que cela notre assemblée
aussi qui peut rester insensible aux
drames humains qui ces dernières
semaines se jouent devant nos portes qui
peut encore parler froidement de chiffr
de l'immigration de contrôle des flux
migratoires quand des milliers de
migrants se noient en Méditerranée qui
peut refuser son empathie à ces
centaines de milliers d'adultes et
d'enfants fuyant chaque année la guerre
la terreur les catastrophes climaques et
que nous accueillons si peu et si mal
qui sait sur nos bancs ce que signifie
quitter sa famille ses amis les couleurs
et les odeurs de la terre où l'on est
Naé personne n'émigre de guetté de cœur
ni ne demande de guetter de cœur l'asile
à un pays qu'il ne connaît pas notre
débat de ce jour doit s'élever au-dessus
de la politique politicienne il existe
d'abord de reconnaître l'intolérable
détresse de ces êtres menacés par des
régimes dictatoriaux qui s'exil parce
qu'ils ont pris des risques et qui font
si souvent honneur au courage humain en
commission un de nos collègues a affirmé
récemment que l'émotion n'avait pas à
interférer dans un tel débat ce qui m'a
beaucoup
touché parce que c'est le contraire que
je pense un législateur sans cœur est un
arbre
desséché rappelons les grands principes
gouvernant le droit d'asile non que je
soupçonne certains de les ignorer mais
parce que les avoirs à l'esprit empêche
de céder au confusionnisme en vogue
entre droit d'asile et immigration si la
protection que nous leur devons découle
de la Convention de Genève sur les
réfugiés du du 28 juillet 1951
elle est également pour nous Français
une exigence nationale
constitutionnelle aussi bien en vertu du
4e alinéa du Préambule de la
Constitution de
1946 que de l'article 531 de la
1958 pour le Conseil constitutionnel le
droit d'asile est un droit fondamental
un principe de valeurs constitutionnell
il ne saurait donc être soumis aux
vicissitudes de nos politiques
d'immigration la Commission nationale
consultative des droits de l'homme dans
son avis du 20 novembre 2014 affirme
ainsi à raison que réduire la question
de l'asile à un problème de gestion des
flux ou de réduction des couts est
inacceptable gardons-nous donc de priver
de sens nos débats
en
instrumentalisant les chiffres en ne
parlant que de gros sous certains ont
déjà tenté de du rapport destbles de la
Cour des comptes dont des extraits sont
parus à point dans le Figaro présentant
la politique d'asile comme
extraordinairement coûteuse et en
faisant la principale source d'arrivée
d'immigrants clandestins en
France revenons plutôt rapidement nous
aussi au chiffres tout à fait public
transparent et montrant bien que la
France n'est plus tout à fait la Terre
d'Asile qu' s orgueillissait d'être
juste un exemple sur les 122800 Syriens
ayant demandé l'asile dans l'Union
européenne en 2014 seul 2084 l'ont fait
en France au contraire de l'Allemagne et
de l'Italie qui ont connu une
augmentation respectivement de 60 % et
de 143 % notre pays est l'un des seuls
en Europe à connaître une diminution de
la demande d'asile que je sais sache
cette diminution ne tient pas à une
amélioration de la situation
géopolitique mondiale nous sommes loin
mes chers collègues d'accueillir toute
la misère du monde le texte initial
encore amélioré par l'Assemblée national
comporter des avancées notables que nous
saluons ainsi nous nous réjouissions au
groupe écologiste que le droit au
maintien sur le territoire français soit
consacré que l'effet suspensif des voies
de recours soit étendu qu'un juge
spécialisé de l'asile soit maintenu et
que le demandeur puisse être mieux
accompagné lors de son entretien devant
l'ofrin malheureusement si les
modifications suggéré par la majorité
sénatoriale venait à être adopté ce
texte loin de mieux garantir des droits
et libertés fondamentaux des demandeurs
d'asile tourneraiit au bouclier sécurité
sacrifiant les plus fragiles à une
obsession
anti-immigration nous écologistes
porterons donc de nombreux amendements
visant notamment à mieux encadrer la
nouvelle procédure accélérée instaurée
par le projet de loi quand à notre vote
final il sera fonction de l'issue de nos
travaux nous écologistes ne sont pas là
pour avaliser un texte satisfaisant
l'agenda politique de l'UMP et duf F
pour qui je cite la lutte contre
l'immigration tient lieu d'unique
programme quand les Français attendent
bien bien attend bien plus de nous des
solutions concrètes et justes à leurs
difficultés économiques et sociales nous
n'apporterons nos voix chers collègues
qu'à un texte humaniste ambitieux fidèle
aux valeurs de la France je vous
remercie chers collègues je vous ai lu
j'ai lu vos déclarations dans le monde
Je que je ne me trompe pas beaucoup
merci merci chers
collègues la parole est à Monsieur
Michel
Savin ah oui pardon madame Ian assassie
1000 excuses 1000
excuse
bon si çaa éé
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre messieur le oui messieur bah
oui mieur les rapporteurs chers
collègues avec le naufrage et la mort de
centaines de migrants au large des côtes
libyennes ces dernières semaines
l'examen de ce texte sur le droit
d'asile s'inscrit dans une actualité
dramatique et malheureusement répétitif
qu'il ne suffit pas de constater ces
drames humains bénéficient d'une large
couverture médiatique mais ils ne sont
que la partie visible de la souffrance
de ces hommes de ses femmes de ses
enfants confrontés après les sentiers de
l'exil au dédal de notre système
d'accueil ces êtres humains ont
plusieurs visages soudanis persécutés
par Boko Haram ringas musulmans de
Birmanie àatride yiDi et chrétiens qui
fuit l'arrivée de l'État islamique en
Irak ou encore banglad réfugiés
climatique victime de la montée des eaux
des peuples entiers donc mais aussi des
individus persécutés en raison de leur
minorité de leur orientation sexuelle
voire de leur simple appartenance au
genre féminin tous ces exemples nous
rappellent avec une férence àité la
nécessité du droit d'asile à cet égard
je tiens à saluer le travail des
associations de soutien aux réfugiés
ainsi que celui des professionnels du
droit car ils incarnent au jour le jour
les valeurs de notre République au côté
des réfugiés ce qui se joue ici est
vraiment très grave c'est le
destin de femmes d'enfants et d'hommes
contraint de s'exiler dans la détresse
en quête de sécurité et d'une vie
meilleure et que l'on renvoie parfois
tout simplement à la mort l'humain
d'abord donc et non les chiffres tels ce
récemment évoqué par la Cour des comptes
et qui qui ont conduit au report de la
publication du rapport de la commission
des lois et ce que j'avais approuvé
d'ailleurs mais à un durcissement de ce
texte que je n'ai pas approuvé malgré le
dévouement et le professionnalisme de
l'ensemble des personnels concernés
notre système d'accueil en matière
d'asile est donc défaillant manque de
place en CAD saturation des dispositifs
d'urgence procédures trop complexes
allongement des délais de traitement
manque d'accompagnement des demandeur
d'asile faible intégration des personnes
ayant obtenu le statut de réfugié ou le
bénéfice de la protection subsidiaire et
cetera et cetera mais de là à considérer
notre système à l'agonie il y a me
semble-t-il de la marge en ce sens la
Cour des comptes nous propose une vision
me semble-t-il très dangereuse de
l'asile une vision purement comptable
arrêtons-nous donc un instant sur les
chiffres en gardant à l'esprit que la
situation de la France est incomparable
à celle du Liban à celle de la Jordanie
ou même de la Turquie qui accueille dans
des structures collectives des centaines
de milliers de réfugiés rappelons-nous
aussi que les Nations Unies estime que
chaque jour 32000 hommes femmes et
enfants sont contraints à l'exil quand
la France fait l'objet de quelques 60000
demandes annuelles et que plus de 80 %
de ces réfugiés atterrissent dans des
pays dit en voie de développement ou en
développement quant au demandeurs
d'asile qui partiennent à chir la
fameuse forteresse Europe des quatre
pays d'Europe ayant reçu le plus grand
nombre de demande d'asile en 2014 la
France et celui y accédant le moins avec
21,7 % des réponses positives ramené aux
populations des États-membres le nombre
de demandeurs d'asile est le plus élevé
en Suède devant la Hongrie l'Autriche et
Malte contrairement aux idées reçues ni
l'Europe ni la France ne sont les
principales zone destinataire du flux
des demandeurs d'asile ces chiffres nous
invitent à combattre les discours
démagogue et c'est ce que le groupe
communiste républicain et citoyen
s'engage à faire tout au long de nos
débats mais au-delà de savoir si l'on
accueille trop ou pas assez de réfugiés
il devient urgent d'apporter à chacun
d'entre eux un accueil de qualité une
réponse juste rapide et effective
l'objectif est de rendre son sens au
droit d'asile il faut réduire les délais
de traitement tout en améliorant la
qualité de la décision objectif tout à
fait complémentaire avec ce projet de
loi le gouvernement propose des
améliorations du droit d'asile et la
mise en lumière de certains grands
principes incontournaable qui reste
toutefois à mieux définir le texte du
Gouvernement apporte plusieurs avancées
issues des directives européennes parmi
lesqueles un meilleur accès à la demande
d'asile avec le droit au maintien sur le
territoire français pour tous les
demandeurs d'asile jusqu'à la décision
définitive de l'OFPRA ou de la CNDA les
conditions de l'examen de la demande
sont également améliorées notamment
j'aimerais bien que monsieur le ministre
il m'écoute quand je lui dis que il y a
des aspects de son projet de loi qui
sont intéressants parce qu'après si
Monsieur carucci le
permet c'est bien vous êtes trop fort
monsieur le ministre les conditions
c'est pour ça que vous êtes ministre les
conditions de l'examen de la demande
sont également amélioré notamment grâce
à une mesure emblématique
l'entretien systématique à l'OFPRA avec
la possibilité de la présence d'un
avocat ou d'un représentant
d'association d'autres avancés proposé à
l'origine donc vous le voyez monsieur le
ministre nous savons reconnaître et
saluer ce ce des mesures qui vont dans
le bon
sens euh pas si rare que ça parce que
vous n'êtes pas souvent là monsieur le
ministre vous devriez m'écouter un peu
plus souvent quand même mais vous ne
m'écoutez pas vous n'écoutez pas les
communistes puce que vous considérez que
ce sont des adversaires aujourd'hui
sans
doute donc oui mais madame madame la
Présidente je suis à la tribune et je
dis ce que j'ai envie de dire à la
tribune donc d'autres avancées proposées
à
l'origine ont été Rogé par la commission
des lois du du Sénat cependant je
plaisante madame je cependant la mise en
œuvre de ces dispositions dépendra
largement des moyens bien évidemment qui
seront alloués pour un hébergement une
allocation à tous les demandeurs à cet
égard nous attendons bien évidemment des
précisions de la part du gouvernement de
plus plusieurs dispositions
d'amélioration sont porteurs de
limitations voire de contradictions qui
vident les droits de leur substance il
en est ainsi du droit d'être assisté par
un tiers fortement mise en cause nous
vous proposerons de faire de cette
mesure une véritable avancée pour
l'accueil des demandeurs d'asile en
permettant à l'avocat ou au
représentants d'association de prendre
la parole et de prendre des notes au
cours de l'entreti tien il en est de
même pour le droit au maintien sur le
territoire dont les dérogations prévues
par votre réforme sont plus étendues que
Cell défin dans la directive européenne
dite procédure qui est pourtant
d'interprétation stricte au sujet de la
transposition des directive européenne
du paquet asile je souhaiterais rappeler
que le législateur ne doit pas se borner
à transposer mais que chaque État est
libre d'ajouter un certain nombre de
mesures qu'ilestime utile pour régler sa
propre situation ainsi gardons à
l'esprit que les principes qui régissent
l'asile sont garantis par notre
Constitution par ailleurs un certain
nombre de mesures que vous préconisés
sont pour nous une source de grande
préoccupation à commencer par les
nouvelles missions qui seront confié à
Lofi qui laisse à penser que des
considérations liées à la gestion des
flux migratoires prendront le pas sur
les besoins de protection des demandeur
d'asile ainsi au regard de la première
lecture de l'Assemblée nationale et des
travaux en commission auquel nous avons
assisté nous sommes je dois dire très
inquiets quant à un discours teinté
d'humanisme mais qui masque mal une
politique du chiffre inavoué et des
préoccupations de gestion des flux à à
cet égard nous sommes vivement opposés à
la procédure d'asile accéléré dès lors
que celle-ci repose sur l'idée que le
détournement du droit d'asile serait
aujourd'hui la règle son champ
d'application bien trop élargie par
rapport à la procédure prioritaire déjà
existante permettra d'une part à l'ofpr
de TR é de manière expéditive
l'essentielle des demandes d'asile et
d'autre part de faire juger à juge
unique à la CNDA dans un délai également
expéditif l'essentiel des demandes
rejetées par le fr ainsi le principe
deviendra assurément la procédure
accélérée à juge unique en mes
connaissance flagrante de toutes les
garanties procédurales et de fonds prévu
par le droit européen national et
international des droits de l'homme de
plus le texte qui est soumis à notre
examen après les travaux de la
commission est empreint de l'amalgame et
croyez bien que je regrette entre
demandeur d'asile et immigré et pire
encore entre demandeur d'asile et
fraudeur un article entier a été donc
inséré pour écarter les étrangers
déboutés de leur demande d'asile de
l'ébergement d'urgence oui madame la
Présidente mais là je plésisente pas
parce que certains orateurs ont dépassé
2 minutes il s'agit là d'une vision
scandaleuse de l'asile qui repose sur
les chiffres par ailleurs
inexistants et qui ne résiste donc à
aucune analyse nous vous opposerons donc
nous nous opposerons fermement à ces
nouvelles dispositions inhumaines tout
comme à d'autres mesures directives ou
discriminatoires finalement nous nous
sommes réjouis de la volonté du
gouvernement d'améliorer le
fonctionnement du droit d'asile en
France deautant que nous plaidons depuis
des années pour une véritable réforme
cependant au regard des arguments que je
viens d'avancer nous ne pouvons que
douter des intentions dont certaines
sont floues et paraissent guidé par une
politique du du chiffre ce qui permet à
la droite sénatoriale comment
non mais je vous ai pas attendu pour
faire des amendements laissz terminer
madame donc ce qui permet puis
laissez-moi finir ma phrase au moins
vous comprendrez le sens de ce que je
veux dire donc ce qui permet à la droite
sénatoriale voilà par l'intermédiaire
des travaux de la commission de durcir
votre texte initial vous êtes content
comme ça voilà c'est dans cet état
d'esprit que nous vous proposerons au
cours des débats non mais vous avez déjà
as vu le groupe communiste qui ne fait
aucun amendement sur les textes ça
n'existe pas donc quand je dis quelque
chose à la tribune bon voilà quand je
dis quelque chose à la tribune c'est
parce que nous le défendrons par voie
d'amendement voilà donc et c'est pour ça
que nous nous proposons donc Madame la
la présidente un certain nombre
d'amendements dans le débat voilà merci
je vais passer la parole à Monsieur le
Ministre plusieurs sujets ont été
évoqués par l'ensemble des sénateurs
auquels je voudrais répondre de façon la
plus précise
possible d'abord sur le phénomène auquel
nous sommes confrontés les phénomènes
migratoires en général et la question de
l'asile en
particulier je voudrais repréciser
devant le Sénat que contrairement à la
crainte qui a pu s'exprimer ou à des
affirmations plus aléatoires qui ont pu
être prononcées dans cet hémicycle la
France n'est pas confrontée à un flux
qu'elle ne maîtriserait pas de demandeur
d'asile depuis 2 ou 3 ans ce n'est pas
la
réalité nous avons même depuis 2014 une
diminution du nombre de demandeurs
d'asile dans un contexte où la pression
migratoire est considérable je donnis
les chiffres pour 2014 c'est - 2,34 % du
nombre de demandeurs d'asile et nous
avons en 2015 alors qu'il y a une
augmentation très significative de
plusieurs euh milliers et même dizaines
de milliers de demandeurs d'asile
arrivant à Lampedusa nous ne sommes pas
du tout dans une situation où en France
le nombre de demandeurs d'asile au début
de l'année 2015
augmente je ne peux pas exclure et je
dois avoir l'honnêteté de le dire devant
la représentation nationale et le Sénat
que la
déstabilisation de la situation
politique en Libye l'inexistence en
Libye d'un état l'impossibilité pour ce
pays de faire face à l'existence sur son
territoire d'organisations qui sont de
véritables organisation de la traite des
êtres humains cela a été dit
d'organisation terroristes aussi
dont on m'indique elles font trafic des
êtres humains pour financer leurs
activités c'est aussi une réalité qui
existe je ne peux pas exclure que cette
situation en Libye ne conduise à une
pression démographique tel que
l'ensemble de l'Union européenne
pourrait se trouver confronté à une
situation extraordinairement difficile
ne pas dire cela dans le contexte auquel
nous sommes confrontés serait une
manière d'occulter une réalité et par
conséquent ne regardant pas la réalité
en face nous nous condamnerions à ne pas
pouvoir la maîtriser à terme donc il n'y
a pas d'augmentation massive du nombre
de demandeurs d'asile en France depuis 3
ans ce n'est pas vrai en dépit de
l'augmentation très forte de la pression
migratoire qui s'exerce sur l'Union
européenne mais il y a un contexte
notamment en Libye qui peut justifier
qu'on se trouve confronté demain à une
situation compliquée il n'y a pas que la
situation en Libye il y a les situation
sur la bande
sahéosaharienne avec des groupes
terroristes et des organisations
criminelles disséminées dans de nombreux
pays qui éprouvent des difficultés au
maîtrise de leurs frontières et je
voudrais terminer par un sujet qui est
Calais parce qu'on n pas prononcé le mot
de Calais et je voudrais dire un mot sur
Calais parce que je suis allé à Calais
voir les migrants dans le terrain qui a
été mis à leur disposition à proximité
de l'accueil de jour que nous avons
coproduit avec la mairie de Calais et
j'ai dit aux migrants demander l'asile
en France et donc il a eu toute une
série de tetter compulsifs de
représentants de sensibilité politique
ont expliqué que j'étais un
irresponsable qui incitait les migrants
à demander l'asile en France comme s'il
n'y avait pas déjà suffisamment de
demandeurs d'asile en France de quoi
s'agit-il quelle est la politique que
j'ai à calis et je tiens à ce qu'elle
soit consignée dans le compte-rendu ici
c'est important d'abord à Calais nous
avons 2000 migrants qui vivent dans des
qui vivaient et qui vivent encore dans
des conditions qui humainement ne
correspondent pas à ce que nous
souhaitons et beaucoup de ces migrants
relèvent de l'asile en France parce
qu'ils viennent d'éritrée ils viennent
d'irac ils viennent de Syrie puis y en a
d'autres qui relèvent de l'immigration
économique
irrégulière nous avons confié à deux
personnalités monsieur Vignon et
Monsieur haribau le soin de conduire une
mission sur l'humanisation des
conditions d'accueil des migrants en
très étroite liaison avec les
associations à Calais cette mission est
remarquablement conduite par ces deux
personnes missionnées le travail avec
les associations à Calais a été
remarquable cette mission sera rendue à
Calais à la fin du mois de mai et elle
permettra de définir les modalités d'un
travail au long cours avec les
associations avec préoccupation
humanitaire j'ai accepté et accompagné
de financement de l'État et de
financement de l'Union européenne la
mise en place d'un accueil de jour à
calis parce que je ne voulais pas qu'en
France il y ait des femmes des enfants
des migrants qui puissent mourir de faim
et ne pas avoir accès au
minimum en terme de soins en terme
d'hygiène en terme d'accès à
l'alimentation qu'on leur devait alors
qu'il revait de l'asile en
France 3ème point
j'ai indiqué que plutôt que de les
laisser entre les mains des passeurs qui
leur promettaiit un eldorado en
Grande-Bretagne alors qu'il y a des
accords les accords du touqué qui
interdisent qu'on les laisse passer que
nous avons un accord avec les
Britanniques que ceux qui n'étaient pas
dublinabl et qui par conséquent relevai
de l'asile en France devait demander
l'asile en France sinon nous aurions un
stock de migrants à caléis qui ne
cesserait d'augmenter donc oui j'ai dit
à ceux qui relevaient de l'asile en
France à Cala qu'il était préférable
qu'il demande l'asile en France plutôt
que de rester entre les mains des
passeurs et des organisations
internationales du crime parce que
c'était de mon devoir moral que de le
faire et que juridiquement il n'y avait
pas d'autre issue que de leur tenir ce
discours
c'était pour des raisons morales pour
des raisons juridiques pour des raisons
aussi d'efficacité de ce que nous
faisons à Cala le seul discours que je
pouvais tenir et par ailleurs et ça
aussi je l'assume devant le Sénat j'ai
indiqué à mes représentants à mes
collaborateurs au force de sécurité qui
dépendent de moi et notamment la DCPAF
monsieur le sénateur vous êtes posé la
question de savoir tout à l'heure si
nous avions assez de moyens pour faire
le travail je leur ai demandé de
procéder à la reconduite à la frontière
de tout ce qui accalais ne relève pas de
l'asile en France sinon il n'y a pas de
soutenabilité de ce que nous faisons sur
le plan humain à Calais
voilà et c'est ça la politique que nous
menons j'aurais plus survoler qu'aler en
hélicoptère j'aurais pu demander aux
forces de l'ordre de disperser la jungle
et sortir de ma première visite à calé
qui aurait d'ailleurs été aussi la
dernière en disant regarder ce dont on
est capable lorsque l'on a le courage
politique de faire des choses absolument
inefficaces et totalement inhumaines et
j'aurais pu ne jamais revenir à Calais
c'est pas ce que je fais j'y suis toutes
les 6
semaines je je travaille en liaison avec
la municipalité de Calais qui n'est pas
de ma sensibilité politique et je viens
rendre des comptes à la population et
aux associations de calis toutes les 6
semaines ou toutes les 8 semaines pour
dire voilà ce que nous faisons et voilà
comment nous
travaillons mais vous voyez que quand on
vient demander dans un lieu qui est un
lieu de désolation que nous améliorerons
par des infrastructures à des migrants
de demander l'asile en France parce que
c'est notre responsabilité morale que de
le faire et qu'il n'y a pas de d'autre
solution en droit que de leur demander
si on veut être efficace dans le
règlement du problème et on n'est pas
sûr de parvenir à les convaincre vous
avez toute une série de commentateurs de
tout poil qui explique que vous êtes un
irresponsable parce que vous incitez des
demandeurs d'asile à demander l'asile en
France alors qu'ils ne peuvent le
demander nulle part ailleurs et que ne
pas demander l'asile en France pour eux
c'est être condamné à l'érance et à la
vulnérabilité pour de long mois donc
voilà ce que nous faisons et c'est la
c'est parce que nous faisons t là en
essayant d'être responsable d'être
rigoureux d'être conforme à ce que sont
les principes de droit que je pense
qu'il est possible que nous ayons sur ce
sujets-là un compromis républicain et
qu'il y a 1000 sujets sur lesquels nous
pouvons nous opposer pour ne pas nous
opposer sur des sujets sur lesquels
l'intensité du drame humain est aussi
grande et la réponse de la République
autant attendu voilà ce que je voulais
dire en réponse à ces différentes
interventions qui ont été très très
bonne et très utile très riche très
dense et je forme le vœux que le débat
que nous allons avoir permette d'aller
au fond des amendement avec un niveau de
précision technique et de d'écoute
mutuelle qui permettent de sortir ce
texte du Sénat en faisant en sorte qu'il
soit meilleur sur le plan des principes
sur le plan du droit sur le plan de la
constitutionnalité je vous remercie pour
ces premiers
échanges merci monsieur le ministre
pour cette intervention précise qui clot
donc la discussion générale donc
l'examen de ce projet de loi se
poursuivra à partir de lundi prochain
avec l'examen des articles pour ce soir
je vais donc lever la séance en vous
donnant d'abord lecture de l'ordre du
jour du mardi 12 mai 2015 donc à 9h30
demain matin questions orales à 14h30
expli de vote des groupes sur le projet
de loi pour la croissance l'activité et
l'égalité des chances économiques de
15h15 à
15h45 vote par scrutin public sur ce
projet de loi à 15h45 proclamation du
résultat du scrutin public sur ce projet
de loi à
16h débat sur l'avenir industrielle de
la filière aéronautique et spatiale face
à la
concurrence à
17h30 question orale avec débat sur les
risques inhérents à l'exploitation de
l'huîre
triploïde voyez que nos sujets vont être
variés demain et le soir débat sur les
conclusions de la commission d'enquête
sur l'organisation et les moyens de la
lutte contre les réseaux djihadistes en
France et en Europe avec cette belle
perspective je vais vous dire la séance
est levée et je vous souhaite une bonne
nuit voilà vous AZ donc pu suivre la
discussion générale sur la réforme du
droit d'asile un texte examiné hier soir
au Sénat et dont l'examen reprendra
lundi prochain nous on se retrouve cet
après-midi pour les explications de vote
sur le projet de loi croissance et
activité le projet de loi
Macron